this is Jocko podcast number 386 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
even after the bullet cut through his
leg and severed his femoral artery
first lieutenant David R Bernstein had a
chance
the shooting stopped quickly and a
soldier trained in combat Medical Care
was at Bernstein's side almost
immediately
helicopters landed and minutes later the
young platoon leader was surrounded by
four surgeons and all the equipment of a
modern Battlefield Trauma Center
Lieutenant Bernstein died that night in
Iraq despite getting the best emergency
medical care the Army had to offer
but doctors who specialize in combat
injuries and who reviewed the details of
the case provided by the sun question
whether the 24 year old West Point
graduate might have lived if the Army
had had something else to offer
a 20 nylon and plastic tourniquet
Bernstein was riding in the passenger
seat of a Humvee near Kirk cook on
October 18 2003 part of a three vehicle
Convoy of the 173rd Airborne Brigade
when Iraqi insurgents ambushed the
Convoy with rifle fire and
rocket-propelled grenades
according to Joshua Sams a former Army
specialist who is driving the Humvee
that day Bernstein was shot through his
left thigh at an angle leaving an entry
wound about an inch and a half above his
knee and an exit wound about four inches
above his knee
Sams who had been trained under the
Army's combat Lifesaver program to treat
trauma injuries
tried to use the cotton straps from a
standard field dressing to put a
makeshift tourniquet on Bernstein's leg
but the material broke apart under the
pressure
by the time he could apply something
more substantial using the Sling from an
M4 rifle and the nozzle from a fuel can
to twist it
Bernstein's blood had soaked the ground
and Sam's could not detect a pulse
I couldn't find a stick Sam's recalls
there was nothing around but grass and
the bag from the Humvee only had
bandages and things
and that right there is a excerpt from
The Baltimore Sun March 6 2005 article
written by Robert little where he
exposed the fact that a
lack of a 20 tourniquet
was costing the lives of American
soldiers and Marines
and Lieutenant David Bernstein was
a heroic guy and apparently was a
complete stud
valedictorian is High School in Suburban
Philadelphia fifth in his class at West
Point
his fault his soldiers talk about him
they said things like it was an honor to
be your RTO you're my hero you were my
hero and you still are
one of his soldiers said I was with
Lieutenant Bernstein when he died
there was not one person at the time
that was not positively influenced by
him
he was never too busy or important to
talk with privates he had a profound
impact on me as a soldier
and a man
so
he died in that tragic situation
but
his death was not in vain
and his sacrifice increased the
military's urgency to get the proper
training and equipment to everyone on
the battlefield and help
bring
tactical combat casualty care what we
call T Triple C more broadly to soldiers
Sailors Airmen and Marines and by the
way the innovation of T Triple C
came initially from
a former seal officer who became a
doctor and who worked at the naval
special Warfare biomedical research
program and wrote an article I think it
was in 1996.
he paired up with another Army doctor
and they wrote an article called
tactical combat casualty care and
special operations and this article set
the stage for a paradigm shift in combat
trauma treatment
and by the way he briefed
and approved
that or he briefed that
innovation of T Triple C
to the leader of the Navy Seals which
was Admiral Tom Richards who's been on
this podcast and Tom Richards had been
wounded in Vietnam and rescued his own
wounded men in Vietnam and he made T
Triple C the standard medical for for
medical treatment in the SEAL Teams in
1997 and eventually from there it spread
to all Special Operations and then
albeit too slowly eventually to
Conventional units
but T Triple C training and the medical
equipment including squared away
tourniquets eventually became a standard
issue and absolutely saved thousands of
lives
in Iraq and Afghanistan
in the next 15 or 20 years
but those lessons
are not just for military personnel
this is something that everyone should
know about
everyone should understand that a little
knowledge and the right gear at the
right time
can keep you
keep your friends keep your family alive
and safe in other words
you have to be prepared
and a friend of mine has made it his new
mission to help people be prepared not
just in terms of medical emergencies
although that's covered but in all
facets of life
that in fact my friend has written a
book about it
his name is Mike Glover he's a former
Green Beret former CIA
contractor he has multiple tours in Iraq
and Afghanistan he's the founder of
field craft Survivor
also the founder of American contingency
he's been on this podcast before number
291 if you want to hear about his
backstory
go and listen to that one but he's back
with us tonight to talk about his new
book
which is called prepared
and how it can help all of us to be more
prepared for Life Mike
thanks for coming back down man thanks
for having me it's always an honor yeah
uh
I don't know if you remember as the T
Triple C sort of spread throughout the
military there was another video I tried
to find it of a Marine in Afghanistan
bleeding out and this was I saw that
video in a time when we had been taught
T Triple C and you could clearly see
what he needed was like a tourniquet on
his leg and and that would have made all
the difference
uh
but that idea of being in situations
where something so simple
makes makes the difference between life
and death the actual difference between
life and death
and how that message
it took so long to get out and I feel
like you right now are the the person
that's trying to get this information
out to the rest of the world and like I
said it's not just medical it's just
it's just survival and life in general
um
what made you decide that you were uh
gonna put this put this book together
yeah it's about two years in the making
I mean it said one of the most difficult
tasks I mean you have to be committed to
it and trying to run a company and do
everything else that we're doing
um it was difficult to say the least but
I thought it was essential because the
concept for the book especially with
penguin random house which isn't
the most conservative
um which the preparedness genre fits in
that uh somewhat
um they're not the most conservative and
so it was hard convincing them of the
message but the idea was to
market and I hate using that word but
that's literally what I want to do
because that's how I had access and
placement to a broader audience because
preparedness is an equal opportunist
disaster will hand you your ass the same
and it doesn't care your your background
your wealth bracket all of those things
so it's very important for me to say hey
distill this information into a few
hundred pages that allow people to
understand what it is so they're not
scared of it they realize that it could
fit potentially into their life without
being intrusive and then benefit them in
being prepared for the future
[Music]
and we'll get into the book one of the
things that I I said this a long time
ago about just training in general so
let's say you're going to train weapons
you're going to train Shadow shooter
pistol and you think to yourself well
what are the chances I'm really going to
get in a shootout okay cool you go
through life you never get a shootout
good for you you still got awesome
benefit from training to shoot you get
to work drills you get to work on your
on your uh hand-eye coordination you get
like to meet people and hang out and do
something competitive like there's a
bunch of other benefits
besides just hey I'm gonna learn how to
shoot case I get into a gun fight
tomorrow because if that's the attitude
you take okay there's a very small
percentage chance that that ha that that
will happen
so maybe I can not do it but also
what if it does happen
where are you at where's your family at
so all these things
um just super important and like I said
to me I look at you right now as the
person that like this doctor who is
trying to change the way I mean the the
way that we used to treat people was
horrible combat medic was just bad like
the I don't know if you went through
this but we someone got shot we'd
immediately give him an IV we wouldn't
even be thinking about it trying to get
an IV in them which is the actual
opposite thing you should do
all that does is increase their blood
volume and it makes their capillaries
open up and they bleed even more it's
worse and that's what we were trained to
do so this guy went on a crusade to get
that stuff changed and I feel that's
that's the Crusade that you're on right
now which is freaking awesome so
with that
I'm gonna go and read a little some
chunks of this book yeah open it with
Jack Carr Jack Carr wrote the forward
and he says This calamity may appear in
the form of a natural disaster a medical
emergency or violent crime modern
societal impulses encourage us to call
9-1-1 in the event of any emergency
someone will be there to answer the call
and send the police officers
firefighters or EMTs to the rescue
or will they
will those First Responders be there in
time defend off an assault put out a
fire or apply a tourniquet
will they arrive after the event to take
reports and clean up the mess
as the saying goes the police are
minutes away when seconds count
whose responsibility is it to protect
you and your loved ones whose
responsibility is it to be ready
unless you are a politician with
taxpayer-funded 24 7 security I can tell
you the answer
it is our responsibility
as Citizens we have responsibilities
that exit extend beyond paying taxes we
have a responsibility to our families
our communities and our country to be
assets not liabilities that means we
need to train
this all boils down to training
hopefully
hopefully you go through life and you
just train this stuff and you don't ever
have to use it that's certainly the hope
um
when you train for this stuff and I go
to your site now watch what you guys are
doing
man it's so helpful for people it's so
helpful for people to go through any
type of training I just was on Twitter
the other day and somebody was asking me
about two daughters what should I tell
them about school sugar I'm like oh
first of all send them to some type of
training Senator fieldcraft survival
Senator sheepdog response get them some
kind of training so they have some
concept of what to do if something
should go wrong
did you when you were in did you run
training uh besides training that you
ran for
um
your local Nationals yeah for sure so I
you know my teams aren't Tom even my
time as an 18 Bravo which I was a
special forces weapons guy so our
responsibility was training the team in
tactics techniques and procedures
overseas and
um it was it was ingrained in me early
on I think even in the Infantry as a
young guy
that training process and protocol like
you said is the method to the madness
it's not necessarily the technical skill
you're training it's the process so it's
the understanding of you know how do you
take in information how are you prepared
to respond and react to immediate versus
imminent threats
that whole thing rewires your brain on
how you approach life environmental
factors threats and I think I've always
been a master trainer especially in my
job in my field but then getting out and
seeing the lack of training in the
civilian world as you described
tourniquets when we went in the military
me and you together in the 90s me on the
Army side of you on the Navy side a
Corvette and a stick was what we were
using to stop the bleed in the Civil War
in the 1860s they utilized a better
version of that it was nearly the same
thing as a tourniquet and then we got
away from it throughout Warfare and many
people paid the ultimate sacrifice
because of that lack of really paying
attention and Vietnam especially so it
wasn't hard to see in civilian life all
of the gaps because there's so many
especially culture I mean you have a
culture here in San Diego with your gym
with MMA okay that is like the
foundation for all the things that we're
talking about but that's training
they're training to do something that's
difficult working with stress factors
and they're building resilience that's
all that training is a lot of guys
gravitate towards guns because guns
shoot move communicates cool but all the
things stop the bleed mindset resilience
they're all equally as important I mean
statistically a lot more of it like stop
the bleed you're more likely to use than
drawing your pistol in a gunfight but if
I told a gun guy hey come to our canning
and jarring course how would that work
out with you like I I'd have to make
that that jar black multicam for them to
show up in order to do it so it's it's
it's always been a passion of mine for
sure I had uh the chief operating
officer at Echelon front it's a woman
named Jamie Cochran and she was moving
across the country and her husband was
help you know getting stuff loaded up in
the truck he was loading I think it was
a mirror mirror broke and cut his arm
like severely and she had to get she had
got the tourniquet and put the
tourniquet on and you know like I'm
pretty sure it saved his life
um
you know like that again who expects to
need a tourniquet on a Saturday
afternoon when you're moving your
household goods like this is not a
normal thing and yet without that
you know he's bleeding out like you cut
your artery and your arm and it's going
to take 15 minutes for an ambulance to
get there you're dead yeah so this stuff
applies for everyone
um any of this stuff can happen at any
time uh I'm glad you're putting it out
there you say in the book I'm going to
push a little bit
principles of modern preparedness are
divided roughly into two parts the
mental versus the physical the internal
versus the external the intangible
versus the tangible a resilient mindset
proper planning situational awareness
and good decision making composed the
first half of these principles this is
the mental intangible side preparedness
it's the piece you can't buy you can't
hold in your hands it's the piece you
have to build these four elements are
about getting and keeping your head in
the game
if and when things go bad
the second half includes principles
regarding everyday carry mobility and
Homestead these are the tangible tools
and assets that you can imagine as a set
of concentric circles of physical
preparedness they constitute the things
you will need on your person in your
vehicle and around your home to be
confident that you won't just survive a
catastrophe but that you'll thrive in it
so this is how you've broken it down so
like what's your mindset and then what
are the physical things that you're
going to do
pretty simple straightforward way to
break things down you have a section
here where you talk about solder City
and you had a scenario unfold where you
guys almost got uh
little little Blue on Blue fracture side
from overhead cover what went down with
that yeah so it was a joint up it was
actually involved the Seal team that
ripped out with you
um and we were doing a hostage rescue in
solder City uh there were ended that
were part of the hostage
um located in the middle of solder City
we were actually set up in containment
on the the basically from uh if people
are familiar with solder City they would
understand this but it was set up like a
baseball diamond so from home to Third
Base we said containment with tanks and
Bradleys I don't know if you remember
this but during that time period task
force was using team Rock which were
Brads and tanks to infiltrate the
location in fact one of the reasons we
started utilizing that is because I
believe three seals it might have been
two seals and a support guy were killed
by an efp going into solder City uh I
saw the vehicle
um post it happening but it happened on
your road you guys's rotation I think
and when that all that stuff unfolded
and all these things were happening
we had to come up with different
strategies including using tanks and
Brads to SEC outer quarter on their
containment and in a nutshell hostage
rescue goes down with the assault force
me and another sniper are co-located
with the big army because they're the
ones who have the tanks and Brides to
Liaison I have an RTO with us that's an
assault Force RTO and as we're
communicating back and forth what turns
into what's what typically was going to
be a host's rescue in and out
unfolded into mighty militia responding
in this big gun fight it was hard for
them to break contact off the assault
force x off the objective and so we were
taking all their bad guys that were
pouring into us and their qrf that were
pointing into them we were dealing with
them the tanks of Bradley certainly were
so we're in a position on a third story
building that as this D evolved it
certainly did uh we got to the point
where the sun was coming up and you know
solder City like that's the worst thing
that you could do unless you're Chris
Kyle during that deployment because he
was he was cleaning some stuff up in
solder City during daylight hours when
that went down we had to figure out a
way to support them as they ex-filled
except we were pinned down in our
location at one point you know air burst
RPGs mortar rounds impacting around us
um direct machine gun fire on top of her
position it was it was the closest I'd
been and the longest version of it of
being killed like I've had close calls
there were instances and it's over this
was like dude this this is not going to
end man
um and it would it was ugly but it was
it was super engaging and I learned a
lot about the incident the the harrowing
part of it was an F-16
which uh I talked to you about
um it was it was a Navy FC I think I
said it was Navy F-16 but it the Navy
was controlling
um an F-16 got it and it was Air Force
bird and that F-16 was in orbit and we
had a controller on the ground with the
assault force and in my position at an
RTO except he couldn't make comms we
were hearing comms but we could transmit
comps and so I'm like yelling at my RTO
and he couldn't do anything and I'm like
dude this is impossible and that bird
comes out of orbit and we hear the call
that he identified bad guys on a rooftop
and we're like on a third story building
I'm thinking and I got a machine gutter
uh from the big army from fourth
infantry division killing bad guys on
the back end of this so if we give up
this rooftop the Brads and tanks who are
you know vectored into the gunfight with
big guns are not going to see these bad
guys come up behind him so it was
imperative that we maintain our position
as this started uh to unfold this bird
come comes out of loiter and my rtos
like I think he's coming out of loiter
for us and I'm like oh no oh no and so
we're pinned down I grabbed a vs17 off
my kit and I had the vehicle version
when I was in recce and Snipes I always
carried the big version because I'd
heard the the horror stories versus the
patrol cap where you have a piece 17
that's big and so I low crawled out to
the middle of it and opened this thing
up it was the size of a car
and the the the fast mover came down and
then pulled up and then strafed the road
that we were on with the tanks of brats
and as he turned he popped his flares or
his his uh one of those surface-to-air
missile flares to basically cut the heat
yeah yeah what they're called he popped
yeah and then he went up into the sky we
all thought we were gonna die and when I
when I when I got back
um my start major
um Pat Medford at the time was my smart
major uh b23 was the crafts art major he
was pissed and he actually called me out
for the Navy and so Green Beret is a
Navy in one room doing an AAR and he
calls me out by name and and luckily the
combat controller I think he's a 2-2 guy
the combat controller was like Hey storm
later that's not how it went down and he
clarified because sart major was like
why would you guys occupy their third
story I said hey we did that because we
had to flex and adapt sitting in a
Bradley in the middle of a gun fight
right supporting an assault Force we
couldn't see anything so we went to the
third story we made a call went to the
third floor he didn't question that but
he questioned like you guys almost got
killed luckily for us the bad guys that
guy was tracking wasn't us wasn't our
position and when he came down he
identified the vs17 and the combat
controller cleared him to come down out
of orbit to do a show of force to
basically lull the gunfight which
allowed us to get into the tanks of
Brads and x-fill in the middle of the uh
in that time mid-morning so the sum up
of that experience in solder city was
was a fascinating business question of
mine which is when you start a business
you try to solve a problem
and I identified in civilian life
because I was now a civilian and I
realized civilian life sucks really bad
it's not great compared to the
communities that we came from there's no
camaraderie there's no culture
that the the big question for me was why
do operators go into Harm's Way
intentionally like if you showed up for
a job interview and the guy's like so
check it out you got the job in 30
minutes you're going to load an mh60 and
we're not gonna have doors on it you're
you're gonna hang your feet off it with
your buddies you're going to go into
combat and you're going to land on top
of the foreign safe house with the bad
guys pouring out of it oh by the way
they have machine guns suicide vest and
they want to kill you you would be like
yeah I don't know about this job but we
sign up for that right it deliberately
intentionally that's what we want and
then we do that job and statistically we
come out on top so I'm like how the hell
does that work and if I told if we told
most people that they would come to us
and say oh it's shoot move communicate
you guys could shoot and move like the
best of them and then we would go oh
yeah yeah yeah but that's not it that's
not what we're talking about it's
everything back to the roots of who you
were when me and you were studying
different versions of it when I was
reading marine sniper and I was setting
up with a BB gun on pigeons like I was
in Vietnam killing bad guys as a 10 year
old right so when when you look at our
past and you look at all the protocols
what it is is it's everything it's
culture paying attention to detail
contingency planning it's it's all the
things that we used to take for granted
and didn't understand that we were
immersed in it like physical fitness it
wasn't going to the gym drinking the
shake flexing in the mirror taking a
picture on Instagram and then getting
back to whatever your daily life was it
was like we lived that my guys would be
like
um Mike we're going to meet you at the
gym or meet you at the uh we're doing a
gym 6 30 to 9 30 and then we're gonna go
to the range I'm like no you're not
you're going to get in full kit and
you're going to run to the range like
what the range is like five miles away
like that's perfect like oh Roger that
that's what we do so it's all about all
of those things in culmination which
create a culture and the truth is so
civilians don't have that culture and my
job my purpose my mission now is with
field Craft Survival developing that
with them yeah there's uh it's sort of
like you
well I don't know what a good example
would be but
you just grow up
and you have these skills that just seem
normal you know they just seem like of
course this is going to be of course
this is what we're doing of course this
is how it's going to go and then you get
out and people don't have those Baseline
skills and they haven't been put in
these pressure situations and so that
can be um it's yeah it's definitely
it's definitely strange to think about
to grow up like you and I did
and just be immersed in that and then
but no one else is I mean that's so
abnormal was it one percent of the one
percent of the American population has
military service
that's not a lot man it's not a lot at
all and you think about all the benefits
that we take for granted of of doing
that like whether it's just getting
knowing how to walk with a rucksack on
to being in pressure situations where
there's loud noises and you're not
freaking out like all those things we
just it's just totally normal for us
this is not normal for 99 literally 99
of the population yeah the the what I've
discovered in all those things and we
did this we called them Gates you know
we we went through blocks of
instructions that had all of these Gates
that dump people out right like I I was
a jtac I was a sniper I did I think
besides dive besides combat dive school
I went to every damn School the military
had to offer every single one of them
the cover course jsox TSC Court like
every single thing I could get my hands
on I went through but I remember the the
feeling in the process like Mike you're
going to this course okay what are tritz
the most people well in week two during
the jtac course at sotac and Yuma this
this gets everybody like okay all right
that's the focus like so I have stretch
stress I have pressure I go in with a
good mindset I have to study I have to
hone my skills I have to hone my craft
and then I come out of it and I did I'm
Different right I'm more resilient
because of that process
that was our entire life like like
people go oh you went to combat you went
to war it's like that was half the
battle the easy battle was going to war
the culmination exercise of what we did
was easy that was the fun part the hard
part is all the things you have to do to
get there and it's a constant cycle so
most guys who like look at a Navy SEAL
or look at a green brand they go I want
to do that they think they go to
selection they get selected they get
their Trident pinned to their chest and
it's the end of that now they just do
the thing you're constantly working and
exposing yourself to doing the thing and
so that culture is completely different
than any world that exists and it's like
the closest thing to the Spartans right
and when you get through that and you
realize the benefit of that when you
communicate and and do so in a tactful
way to a civilian and they get a little
bit of that they lose their mind because
they're like oh my God and I already
know because I walk through here and and
your gym has it when there's guys like
if there's a dude like in the mirror and
he weighed himself and he looked at
himself in the mirror and the dude was
ripped up and then he flexed in the
mirror and I'm like that's right you're
breeding Warriors here so we need to
breed more resilient human beings that
are more capable and more prepared yeah
there's I used to I when I try to
simulate was there's different kinds of
stress and one of the types of stress
that we would get in the military is
like oh your uniform is wrong or like
when you're going through boot camp your
uniform's messed up there's a certain
level of stress and even going through
like CQC training hey you were too far
off the wall are you penetrated too deep
or you didn't penetrate deep enough like
there's stress where you know what
you're doing is wrong you don't want to
look like an idiot you're trying to do
the right thing and that does create a
stress and some people freak out with
that kind of stress there's also stress
what I tried to make stressful when I
was running training was
this is freaking Mayhem and if someone
doesn't make a decision everyone's gonna
die that's the kind of stress that I try
to put it wasn't a technical stress it
was like a situational stress to lay
down on people and it's actually I think
both of those type of stresses
produce a benefit you know whether it's
just stress from people yelling and
screaming at you because you did the
wrong technique at a certain time to the
stress of like oh I need to make a
decision and there's total chaos going
on and those stresses are both different
they both produce benefits and that's
why I think the military
provides both of those type of stresses
to two people to make them more
resilient yeah you're con we're
constantly immersed in stress and that's
a good thing because you become a
conditioned for it I talk to people when
I when I talk about these preparedness
seminars I talk to them about the
detriment of stress and and very few
people have seen the detriment of
conditioned for stress
you've seen it before I know you have
I've been standing I remember standing
on a hit once and we it was a suicide
bomber and all this stuff and it was
melee we had a little birds raining down
brass on us because they're marking our
position and they're using us as the
friendly forward line and all hell's
broken loose the v-bit just detonated
inside the carport and at one point
during the gun fight there's a lull
because everything's on fire all the bad
guys are burning in an open field and I
look to my right and the little birds
still doing gun runs and there's brass
running down on our helmets and I look
at all the guys and they're all standing
just joking and hanging out and I'm like
can you guys at least take a knee I mean
you ever heard of grazing fire like
taking knee we're in an open field
they're like oh yeah like we should
probably take a knee so there's like a
detriment uh which is the far right side
but most people don't know that
bandwidth they've never seen how they
potentially operate and I think it's the
detriment of training period because you
get a lot of guys who on flat ranges Run
and Gun it's Corey graft and they fall
in love with themselves and I often get
these guys come into our training
courses and they do things like I don't
know like drawing the pistol shooting
the Target and then bringing the gun
back in retraction and I say to him like
why are you doing that well what they're
really doing is they're resetting the
rep I'm like in a combat situation when
you're engaging the enemy that you just
shot you're resetting the rep there
isn't a rep a reset you need to stay
engaged conscious to understand what's
going on and most people don't
understand how that works so there's a
technical expertise there's a technical
understanding because it's displayed on
social media but there's no context and
I think a lot of what we're doing is
trying to take that like you said low
grade and high grade stress introduce
that to everybody and then show them
they can operate cleanly they don't have
to be operators but they could operate
cleanly somewhere in between if they
have that understanding and stress yeah
uh just to just to bring in everybody
not just combat here you say in the book
we like to think about combat and
catastrophe as distinct ideas as
different things but qualitatively
they're the same a malevolent force that
is trying to kill you check surround
sound chaos and uncertainty everywhere
you turn check sudden violent terrifying
incidents that can create lasting trauma
check acts of gods or of Madness that
defy explanation check the only
difference between combat and
catastrophe is that combat is a choice
while catastrophe is something that
happens to you or around you regardless
the only things that can equip you to
respond to either that can insulate you
from the Fatal consequences of either
that you can set up and thrive in and
after either are the pillars of
preparedness
and then you go on the same catastrophe
you can derive the same kinds of
benefits from sufficient preparedness we
get from them in combat when you remove
the Tactical military layer from
preparedness and strip it down to its
foundational elements it becomes clear
as day that an integrated sense of
preparedness can help any person out
there prevent survive and overcome any
kind of disaster they might face in this
book I'm going to show you how
and regardless as I said earlier if you
are prepared and you are doing things
that are making you more mentally
resilient you could never face any kind
of catastrophe ever and your whole life
is still going to be better you're gonna
get better at everything that you do
you're gonna be better at dealing with
some employer that's freaked out or
employee that's freaked out you're gonna
be better when some you know uh client
comes in is yelling and screaming or a
customer like all these things you're
gonna get better at all of them so this
is just an upgrade in life regardless of
whether you and we'll get to some of the
ignorance and and arrogance that people
one of the excuses that people have
we'll get to that but if you're not now
thinking you know what I really live in
a gated community and there's nothing
really like this is going to happen cool
good but you can still benefit from this
and then in the offense chance that
something does happen you'll be even
more prepared there's like a this is a
win-win across the board it's what it is
uh catastrophe is an equal opportunist
it doesn't care about your personal
wealth or social status your religious
convictions or how nice of a person you
are catastrophe doesn't operate or
execute on timelines constraints it
doesn't have an objective or a goal
outside of turning your life to complete
and utter chaos the question here is are
you prepared are you ready to be
confronted head on by the worst day of
your life in preparedness it is often
said mindset is everything you hear that
phrase a lot from those who have built a
business around the idea of improving
your mindset what I've often found is
that so-called experts don't have any
tangible advice for improving mindset
like how do I actually make my mindset
better and what is mindset in the first
place let's start off by answering these
basic questions you say a little bit
forward when I talk about having the
right mindset and by the way I'm just
skipping through like reading some
highlights of the book the book is
there's so much more information here
I'm just going to hit some highlights
get the book so you can get all these
details fast forward a little bit when I
talk about having the right mindset or
what I'm referring to is resilience
having the ability to withstand the
initial shock when catastrophe strikes
and then having the wherewithal to
respond in a timely constructive manner
a resilient mindset is everything
because your ability to withstand an
acutely traumatic event and respond to
it may very well mean the difference
between life and death doesn't get more
more conclusive to that than that uh
example I like to use a lot
if you do Jiu Jitsu
you are used to people grabbing you
manhandling you trying to throw you down
like you're used to human physical rough
contact
if you don't do Jiu-Jitsu you're not
used to that so if you're out in the
street
and someone grabs you and you do Jiu
Jitsu you immediately are comfortable
with it like I am so comfortable when
someone grabs me I get I'm not smiling
right now I get a smile on my face when
someone grabs me it makes me a little
bit happy
you know because I'm like oh I get to do
my thing
if you're not used to that you are going
to freeze up and we'll get to that whole
thing
the conditioning the mental conditioning
that you get
from that from being in that environment
on a regular basis is going to make you
prepared to act that much quicker well
it's the same thing when shots are fired
it's the same thing when there's an
explosion if you don't have if you've
never been through that before if you're
not prepared for it at all it's going to
take you out of the gate it's going to
take you three seconds or five seconds
just to freaking comprehend what's
happening and get your if you're lucky
you'll be able to get your body to do
something in three seconds or five
seconds and sometimes it's it's minutes
you know sometimes people just
completely lock up I've seen that before
where I'm looking at a guy like dude get
move hey push forward they're not moving
and you got to go up and physically get
them out of the way because they're not
moving they're frozen
so getting that mindset
it takes a little bit of practice
getting that resilient mindset where you
can actually make something happen you
have to put yourself in those situations
um
and you go into that here you talk about
the nervous system you talk about
voluntary movements are Guided by the
somatic system which are made up of
sensory and motor neurons neurons
yeah I mean don't get scientific on me
over here Mike whether you realize or
not you have conscious control of all
the movements of the somatic system
uh the autonomic system is best
understood in two parts sympathetic
nervous system the SNS and the
parasympathetic nervous system the PSNS
the sympathetic nervous system governs
your fight or flight response to
external physical threats and acute
physiological or acute psychological
stress this is what's important about
this stuff is
understanding what's going on inside
your body is going to make it easier to
recognize that it's happening give you
some ability to get control of it detach
from it a little bit and that's why it's
important that you cover it in here
um whereas the SNS controls the fight or
flight in this capacity to said that the
PSNS
governs the rest and digests so you got
your PSNS is working all the time to to
digest your you know food you don't have
to think about that
um but the SNS controls fight or flight
so this is like wins when some shit's
going sideways
you got some examples in here and you
talk about this um
if you're reading this book there's a
good chance you or someone you know has
experienced a traumatic event and
discovered in real time that the
disconnect was too wide then to delay
too long
you neither fought nor fled at least not
quickly enough maybe you froze and this
is something that's I don't know when
they started talking about freeze fight
or flight freeze that's another one they
added in you know when they added that
in yeah it's I mean there's there's
controversy over that even statement of
the freeze component but it's recent
it's the last couple decades they've
added that in also some people don't
believe in the freeze no because there I
mean there's there's a couple components
one there's a like you said we're
resting and digesting we're just hanging
out I got more energy from this drink uh
this choco go right now which is great
by the way
um I I intentionally sometimes take this
when I was a team guy we were talking
about team guy stuff uh before we get on
the podcast when I was a team guy my
heart rate was in the 30s with 37 beats
per per minute uh at a bigger size guy
it was I had good cardio and I had to
take things like this to activate and
keep my system going because at a rest
and digest phase you're sluggish you're
slow your brain's not cognitive you're
not working but when you start to
elevate that you're getting I've always
said yurx dots and it's yurkis dots and
curve of performance is with an
elevation of a measurable beat per
minute that's typically how we regulate
it or how we measure it when you elevate
to 120 to 150 beats per minute you start
to see results in performance increase
so that's not a necessary shift in your
central nervous system but what people
don't realize is if you're not
conditioned for stress and something
happens like you're about to hit the
deer you almost hit it and you feel that
surge of cortisol and adrenaline that's
you shifting from a rest and digest just
hanging out chilling to shifting to a
parasympathetic nervous response right
so when you when you think about these
things uh parasympathetic I'm sorry
parasympathetic to sympathetic when you
think about this fight flight response
it's a Mobility tactic for the human
body to survive under I would say
ancestral and Primal conditions right
it's not a very good modern tactic
because back in the day we were hucking
Spears or running from the saber-toothed
tiger that was beneficial
that now has changed because of the
introduction of technology so even if I
have to dial 9-1-1 and people have seen
this if you've been in a fender bender
and somebody is speaking really loudly
because they're really stressed and they
don't know what to do and they're almost
in a fight or flight response nearly
probably at 150 beats plus per minute
they were being overwhelmed by the
environment and so they're in a
sympathetic nervous response the problem
is we are not conditioned nor have we
correlated to the environment in time so
what I mean by that but our our
mechanism to measure these things in the
environment has changed so when you
spend 99 of your day on your cell phone
in a cubicle not walking not moving not
exposed to environments
your ways to deal with stressors change
so now you see people who are in traffic
in San Diego
literally Road raging in a sympathetic
response clutching the wheel smashing
their head on the steering wheel because
they are literally in fight or flight
now the problem with the the freeze
component is the phrase component is a
tactic but if we take a sympathetic
nervous Spike of cortisol norepinephrine
and it increases performance and we
freeze the benefit is to evade capture
or evade detection or evade getting it
getting attacked
that's beneficial in the moment but
there's a different component on the
back side of that that by the way is
called hyper arousal because we're hyper
stimulated
when you look at on the back end of that
there's actually a story that I talk
about in the book about Virginia Tech
and the moment is tragic this was first
documented by Amanda Ripley in the book
Unthinkable which is a great book
but Amanda talks about how one of the
students in the classroom if you're not
familiar with it Virginia Tech wears a
mass killing where 31 students were
killed most of them in one building most
of them in a series of classrooms were
the shooter with two pistols using one
pistol at a time went from classroom to
classroom executing students 90 plus
percent of the casualties that were
killed or injured were shot in the back
of the head so basically people were
freezing in place except most people
identify that as part of the sympathetic
response hey these guys went to fight or
flight or freeze they froze they
couldn't move
that is one part of it what this kid
experienced in a classroom where I
believe there was 13 students total nine
of them died
he's one of the survivors but he was
never shot
is he remembers the shooter coming into
the classroom and he remembers
contorting his body and he doesn't know
why but he thought if I can tort my body
he would recognize me as being
potentially already shot or killed and
he would bypass me now he he thinks
about that and hindsight is an
observation likely in the moment he
became hypo aroused so he went from this
elevation oh my God what's going on to
hypo aroused and he shuts down now we've
seen this in in nature this is the faint
response the Fawn response the playing
possum and what we've discovered in
human beings about this phenomenon is in
this particular case this is proof of it
in this particular case he said he
thought at one point he was shot because
the shooter bypassed him the shooter
left the classroom after shooting
everybody around him loaded which was
what he did that was his sop reloaded
came back in the classroom and went
through a second pass bypassed him again
at one point he had disassociative a
disassociative experience which is
common under this amount of stress it's
actually the same amount of stress that
you'll see in children and women in
sexual assaults where they're like I
don't remember and I couldn't do
anything because I felt paralysis or I
felt paralyzed most of those victims
accused themselves of not fighting and
they live with that regret the problem
is nobody's talked about the chemistry
the chemistry and being hypo aroused
just like the Fawn that faints after the
cheetah is chasing its ass and it just
collapses in in place most uh peop most
scientists believe that the reason that
takes place is because a healthy animal
that's trying to survive would never eat
or risk eating a tainted with that virus
bacteria or even injured potential
animal that could affect its survival of
its species right so when this kid
collapsed in place he said at one point
he went to move and his legs wouldn't
move he felt numb and he went man being
shot isn't so bad he thought he'd been
shot so he segment meaning
disassociative memories
he's going to move and can't move and
the reality is opiates are flushed into
the system some scientists think it's
because
um one for pain right because it's about
to get mauled to death two for the
transition from life to death to be a
little bit easier
and in this case when he went to move
the opiates that flush in the system
shut him down so he's no longer hyper
but he's hypo aroused and he's basically
quit in place
the reason I talk about this in this
book is because every single human being
has this potential in them so if you
think about what resilience is it's
technically this band of quit that lives
in you I've seen it you've likely seen
it in combat I I was on an operation in
Iraq with seals uh it was a co uh joint
operation
me in an endage Iraqi so it's the I
think it's like the it was either the
Emergency Response Unit that operated
out of Baghdad or the Iraqi
counterterrorism unit I can't I can't
remember which one but I was in a ditch
so the Navy uh the seals that were with
us were in a compound they had just
cleared a building and I was on the
outer part of that compound clearing a
ditch with one of my Iraqis and we're
clearing it together and he takes a
white light and illuminates the ditch
and we're under knots and as soon as he
illuminates the ditch a PKA machine
gunner on top of a rooftop opens up on
our position I fell on my ass and I had
to suppressed him for and I start
shooting at the point of origin
and he rolls into the fetal
um one of my buddies Uh Kevin Owens is
on a dual twin 40 or twin 240 machine
gun he opens up on it and all the seals
on the compound wall open fire above us
so we now have like intersecting
interlocking sectors of fire all over
the place and I'm like okay this is
standard like get your ass up let's go
let's low crawl back to the uh the
compound so I call over the net I'm like
hey guys I'm coming in front of you
they're shooting over us
and he won't move
he is Frozen in position in place but I
don't think it was the fight fight or
freeze he was so hypo aroused as a
survival mechanism his body shut down I
dragged his big ass uh 20 yards to the
compound wall pulled him in and when I
set him up I was like dude are you good
like I at one point I thought he was
shot slapped him around a little bit and
he's like
Mike I have no idea what happened it has
no recollection of the memory doesn't
understand why he's shut down and he's
one of my good Iraqi operators but what
people never have recognized before in
this conversation is you have triggers
you have triggers typically from trauma
that could shut you down so if you're
abused as a child if you were blown up
an IED whatever it is that trigger can
be initiated it could shut you down and
potentially there's no chance of you
fighting anymore because your system not
your brain your brain has already told
your system now your brain's checked out
because your body has quit on you that
is why resilience is so important
because the further we can create a gap
between that moment in time as a
threshold the more resilient we could be
and I think that line is like right
behind that yurkis Dotson curve and it's
like over to the right side of it you
could draw a line in the sand right
there and and create as much callous on
that as as possible to get the hell away
from it that's what you need to do I was
thinking as I was reading that story
about the kid uh paralyzed mentally or
whatever paralyzed during that shooting
at Virginia Tech I was thinking
it it must be that because if it wasn't
imagine how hard he would be breathing
if he was like conscious and aware and
like his body was working
there's no way someone would think he
was dead because
like being around scared people I've
been around scared people they freaking
they freak out yeah you know and you
also get around scared people that they
look like they're dead they don't move
yeah so the sexual assault thing is a
good point in case when you're talking
about this because we have a huge
documented uh understanding of this but
most sexual assault victims
recollect their experience as
it's a disassociated Memory they don't
remember a lot of it and sometimes blame
themselves because they're like I don't
know I can't remember like what do you
mean you can't remember like you were
there like well their system was shut
down what do you mean you didn't fight
like I feel guilty I should have fought
you couldn't have fought because if
you're hype or aroused and your system's
flush with opiates and breaking down
you're going through the most traumatic
event ever and it's almost like shell
shock which you know we we associate
sympathetic responses and like losing
your your stuff your marbles and you're
crazy but we forget there's a whole
component of being shell-shocked under
the most difficult of trauma where
people they like you said they look like
they're dead they can't move and there's
there's science to back that and I think
that's important for people to
understand we see an officer involved
shootings that we analyze we see it
talking to First Responders talking to
military it exists we've witnessed it
before in combat
um but it's not understood and like you
said before the more we understand about
this the more we could identify and
diagnose our own symptoms in real time
when it's happening to us
here you're going to say and this is
pretty much what you just said but in
the book you say um the one thing that
stabilizes every curve that neutralizes
or equalizes the impact of complexity
familiarity and confidence is experience
exposure the less stress and discomfort
you've experienced in your life the
greater the likelihood that you may shut
down in a crisis that's called fragility
the Grady greater variety of stressors
you have been exposed to the more often
you have been tested by the unfamiliar
or the complex the more likely you are
to withstand a traumatic event and
respond effectively that is called
resilience
ah you think about what they do in like
our selection
they're just conditioning you for
freaking Mayhem you're just getting used
to it the first time I ever got shot I
was like oh cool I was just like man
right on cool here's what we're gonna do
like just so used to just dumb
getting blown up for you know grenade
Sims going off next to your head and
stuff like that you're like okay cool
um
exposure is the key to building a
resilient mindset because everyone I
mean everyone can freeze under stress
even the most hardened combat tested
Special Operations Personnel I've seen
it with my own eyes it even happened to
me
so like your first time you go through
this in the book what happened there so
I was in Afghanistan and
Afghanistan at the time it was during
the operation Red Wings I was there
during that same rotation and it was
chaotic I mean that that year was a
pretty bad year 0405 were bad years and
when we were there in our particular
five Firebase which is Firebase Norway
which is east of operations Red Wings up
in the uh cam Dash area on the border
with Pakistan and even near China and
chitral in that area it was Osama bin
Laden's stomping grounds that area was
known especially because it was tied
into the Hindu Kush for Rocket attacks
motor attacks all indirect fire because
they they own The High Ground
our Firebase was right off of the river
the konar river surrounded by High
Ground now we had observation posts but
bad guys could walk in and around that
area set up mortar positions and Rocket
positions the classic rocket that was
used which is a Russian and Chinese made
munition it's the 107 millimeter rocket
I mean it's about this big a 107
millimeter rocket for those listening to
this has a stabilizer rear or or front
and aft that allow it to be shot off
anything I mean it's typically shot out
of a pod I think a mark 21 pod
and the the reason the Taliban like this
is because you could put it on a rock
and as long as you have good line of
sight you could lob it and the rocket
would Propel its fuel source and it
would shoot but it would self-stabilize
you do that with most rudimentary
Rockets they would just launch and lob
into the ground but this once you took
trajectory would take that line of sight
that it launched off of
so it's self-stabilized and has a kill
radius of about 25 yards 25 uh 25 meters
so it's it's lethal but it also sounds
like a freight train now when I went to
Afghanistan fresh out of the Q course my
mindset was like small unit tactics
Pineland you know Green Beret and Camp
McCall I'm Ready for War in like Vietnam
but we go to Afghanistan and I'm like oh
wait there's no trees my carbine will do
nothing here you know I'm like staring
at my gun like this isn't the right gun
and we were out on a hlz helicopter
landing Zone picking up bottles of water
that had exploded in a CDS bundle drop
uh this this C-130 went to resupply us
we had no means of resupply and this
dude was a big old he did not want
to go down and fly and nap the river
which I'll give credit where credit's
due the latter version of that which is
a C-130 pilot not the Earth and like was
a hundred feet over a Firebase and
dropped it on top of our bases the
parachute didn't even deploy just blue
uh water bottles everywhere but this guy
lobbed it over the Hindu Kush and they
landed and exploded everywhere so all of
our bottles of water which was our
actual water that we needed to survive
was broken up and was everywhere so we
got 12 Green Berets and 100 ended on in
the open picking up bottles of water
like policing up water we're out there
how many days have you been out here at
this point this is not long this is like
a couple days so you never you haven't
been shot at yeah
so I'm sitting up there and I got my M4
strapped to my back because I'm picking
up bottles of water and the endanger on
the Riverside with some of the SF guys
and they're picking up bottles of water
and we hear I hear
and I'm like looking around all the
endage because they know what that sound
means they start breaking contact and me
and the guys would look at each other
like what was that and then you hear and
it's like it just remembers like
Apocalypse Now or like the Napalm hits
and they just blast everywhere it wasn't
that dramatic but they were impacting
around us and I'm like dude we're gonna
die picking up bottles of water this is
not going to be a cool story but I
remember even reflecting with my M4 like
thinking oh man I need to get on my gun
except my gun was completely incapable
of doing anything right that point of
origin was kilometers away so I ran
behind a vehicle and I hid
and I remember like one I went into a
sympathetic nervous response I was
probably on the high end of the Curve
and a few things took place
one I froze in that moment it was about
three to six seconds before I had to
talk myself getting back into the fight
because I realized people were screaming
my name like Mike what are we doing and
I was in charge of Base security brand
new staff sergeant my job at that
Firebase with a hundred Afghans and 12
Green Berets was forced protection for
our Firebase it was my entire job and
I'm like oh my God I don't even like
what do I do so I went into this mode
where I started executing all these
orders and getting things lined out
a couple things one I screamed
everything and I didn't have your pro on
but I was screaming and I remember guys
civil Affairs guys who had been in
combat who'd been in gunfights looking
at me while I was screaming and I'm
going why are you screaming and I'm
going I don't know why I'm screaming and
so I'm running all over the place one
thing that stuck out I actually have the
scar right here it's on the on my on my
hand right here
um I ran down to the river and there's
concertina wire and I remember blindly
grabbing Constantino wire not even
thinking about it for a second because
the guys were on the other side of it
they had used the glove and they had
separated it they went down to pick up
the water and it was closed so when I
ran up to it I knew they had to get up
and in the vehicles out of the hlz I
just grabbed it and ripped it open
didn't fill a thing then we got in back
into the base and I actually got on a 50
cal at one point and I'm on The Mod
deuce and I'm shooting the point of
origin and I'm letting it rip no ear
protection when it's all said and done
complete auditory exclusion which is a
sign of the indication you're in a
sympathetic nervous response probably on
the far right side of it like not the
side that you want to be on right you're
you're you're in chaos so all this stuff
happens and I realize like in the AAR of
myself dude I sucked like I was not as
cool as I thought I was going to be
under pressure under Fire because I
didn't expect my first Contact to be a
107 millimeter rocket I mean if you
would if if I could have gave some
commands and some orders to Camp McCall
I would have had them using simulators
every single op and lobbing them at
students because I was prepared for the
close contact in FM 7-8 but I was not
prepared for this indirect firing
capability that was evaporating human
beings off the planet and it changed my
perspective on a lot of things including
my willingness to stick to a plan
because I had a force-based protection
plan that put my guy In Harm's Way
because I wanted to prevent the direct
attack except if I flexed on that plan
they potentially would have been
evaporated by a 107 millimeter rocket or
or worse so I actually had to take a
step back and go man you're not as cool
as you thought you were this is real uh
the stakes are high and don't be afraid
to adapt because you're operating at the
speed of War yeah and what's you know
I'm sitting over here laughing at this
story and and you're laughing too
the thing is if you take someone that
hadn't been through training that hadn't
been through these stress inoculation
that that wasn't prepared like what you
did look you're over here kind of uh uh
critiquing yourself that you took three
to SEC six seconds in your first time in
combat to like make things happen
that's freaking awesome like on a normal
standard of a normal human being that's
outstanding then you went down you got
the guys back in the compound like you
made a bunch of decisions you got up on
the 50 cow you started returning fire
that that that all is look you might not
be able to brag about it amongst your
teammates
yeah exactly but you know you do that in
a in a in a situation
where there's something totally
unexpected and you're a civilian you're
a freaking hero you're a hero if you do
any of those things
and that's why you know the training
that you went through going up into that
point is so important because a lot of
people would have just completely Fallen
apart they wouldn't have even got they
wouldn't even Run for Cover they
wouldn't even Run for Cover so that
shows the effectiveness of the training
and I've got a bunch of stories of guys
getting gunfights the first gun fights
that they were in and they did freaking
outstanding outstanding uh my buddy Seth
first gun fight he ever got into
uh in the malab district over of ramadi
they're getting pinned down he's sitting
next to this major we pinned down behind
a wall the major looks at him he's got
big eyes and Seth's like hey I'll get
some guys we're gonna go to that flank
him from that High Ground over there in
that building he goes and executes it
gets back and the guy's like man you
must have been in a lot of urban combat
incest like that was my first gun fight
yeah which is awesome right that's
awesome you know of course Seth was like
dude I think I do you know he was kind
of critiquing himself as well but that's
what this book is about is is and that's
what this section is about how do you
get yourself how do you train yourself
and get used to stress so when stress
comes for real you're at some level
inoculated to it because like you said
look you might not have performed to the
level that Mike Glover wants to perform
to in the first time in combat
but that's still a freaking Big W across
the board you get your guys back through
the uh barbed wire like you you made
stuff happen
that's what we want to do what you don't
want to do is get in a situation where
you lock up where you freeze where you
completely freak out when you just don't
make anything happen and that's what
this book is about
um you say stress training starts by
finding the edge of your comfort zone
and learning how to adapt along the way
if you start to get overwhelmed and feel
yourself shutting down there are two
simple tactics to employ conscious
breathing and self-positive and positive
self-talk stop take a big breath hold it
big breath out pause repeat when you
feel yourself coming back to Earth start
telling yourself I can do this I got
this I know what to do repeat say it out
loud so you can hear it not just think
it it might sound a little woo-woo like
we're in a meditation class or a yoga
retreat but it works I know because it's
exactly what I did as I hunkered down
after that 107 millimeter rocket
exploded I took a couple deep breaths
told myself Mike you got this you know
what to do six seconds later my head was
back in the game not only we reap the
benefits of the off-gassing of carbon
dioxide allowing oxygen back in your
brain but the conscious thought of
breathing will plug you back in reality
being able to pull yourself together
like this under stress is of utmost
important importance it is at least as
important if not more so than knowing
exactly what to do in a crisis because
in the modern world many of the actions
we must take an emergency to save our
lives require fine motor skills
foreign
I had speaking of ceph we're doing
vehicle iads vehicle median action
drills out in the desert
he's a young platoon commander and I'm
behind him in his vehicle and he's got
four or five vehicles and they're going
through the desert and vehicle uh
reactive targets pop up and they start
shooting so the Gunner starts shooting
at these Targets this is just out in the
desert here not not a real operation
and I'm watching him you know I'm like
his boss or whatever so I'm watching him
to see what he's going to do and he's
not doing anything and he's not doing
anything and he's not doing anything
and you know finally after a while
somebody makes a call and they kind of
maneuver the vehicles out of this
contact
and so we get back to do another
iteration we get back you know while the
other platoon is going we're sitting
there reloading ammo and whatnot and I
take a sharpie magic marker and I write
on the window in front of him on his
Humvee I write one relax two look around
three make a call
and I'm like hey dude next time you hear
that 50 cal go off I want to just follow
these steps right here that's what I
want you to do and he goes Roger that so
we roll out again and I'm looking over
his shoulder and and the targets pop up
and the shooting starts and I see him
you can't hear anything so I'm just
looking at him and I see him go
I'm like okay you got one and then he
like starts turning his head he opens
the door a little bit looks at the
vehicles behind him I'm like okay he's
got two and then he gets on the radio
and he says you know strong right or
whatever
I'm like that's it
that's what you got to do just relax
look around make a call that's what
you're talking about here you know when
you say to yourself if you and it's so
important to recognize that this stuff
is happening this is why the training is
important because if you don't do this
kind of training you don't get used to
going oh wait I'm about to lose it right
here I need to freaking settle down or I
have lost it I need to give come back to
reality I talked about this a bunch with
uh Andrew huberman who's a
neuroscientist
and what I realized is
one of the things that I used to do is I
didn't want to sound like a baby on the
radio you know you don't want to sound
like you're freaking out on the radio so
whenever I get on the radio I'd be like
hey we need to build to move the
building for 39 right now you know like
just I was trying to sound like a
fighter pilot right you know
you don't want to do that because you're
going to catch a lot of for it
so I'd always just like all right get in
position
hey everyone we need to get a Building
47 now and like okay cool
but that's not only helping you sound
cool which is important but more
important it's helping you relax it's
helping you calm down it's helping you
get back to Earth
so
these things are things that you can
train
that's what they are these are things
that you can train and that's uh
critical absolutely critical yeah that
that as a leader that competence which
is sounding uh squared away over the
radio is breeding that confidence in the
guys you know it's and it's and it's
addictive you know like people want that
voice of reason and logic and a lot of
these things I'm afraid the place that
we're at now is a culture in society is
the fear right it's one of the things
that like I feel in this purpose of all
the things that we're doing whether it's
our prep live show on YouTube me doing
this book all these things that I do
constantly thinking about preparedness
is like I'm fighting a battle because
the battle is
I'm fighting for attention against a
cell phone or a TV that is breeding
weakness in our society not only is that
weakness translate to a lot of negative
impacts but ultimately it creates a
complacent culture and Society so we are
more complacent than we've ever been in
the history of our country but also at
the detriment of a lot of socioeconomic
issues which are causing every spike in
all the bad
to go up and all the good literally to
go down in all the statistics
homelessness has gone up violent crimes
have has gone up
um drug addiction and overdosing has
gone up mental health issues mass
killings you can name it it all stems
back to where we're at on the scale of
of being resilient and and we're not as
a society so all the time that when I'm
doing these things and I'm talking about
all these elements I'm actually thinking
man are we winning and we're not and in
the war we're losing maybe I'll win the
battle I get 200 people to show up and
think about preparedness and they walk
away and they go man we should probably
start putting our cell phones down
paying attention to our kids and
actually doing things that benefit our
survivability uh not just as like the
literal sense but I mean building
resilience back in our family like let's
start from day one
but I feel like ultimately uh we're
losing the war
um one battle at a time but ultimately
we're losing yeah that's a horrible
thing to think about if you think about
if I'm going out in the world and I'm
not resilient what is my reaction to
pressure my reaction to pressure is go
back to my phone where it's safe and I
have control over it yeah and so then
the more I go out in the world and I
feel more pressure I go back to my phone
I go back to things that are fake and
things that don't pressure me and I hide
there and then where am I in life yeah
that's a terrible and when I look at you
like you you're a good example of this
when you go out into the civilian world
you're an anomaly and people go what the
what is that what is that what is that
thing that this dude is
when me or me and you are working
together we're peer-to-peer was like
that's our world and it's like we
identify we know exactly what that is
but when a surveyance sees you it's like
you're an alien so think about how from
their perspective how far away in scale
you are from the complacency that we are
so now young men who grow up they they
look at the picture of you doing the
thing and think I want to do that and
they will never in their life attempt
anything close to that right so they
could virtue signal about it they could
talk about it they could post meme tweet
tweet about it but they won't actually
ever do it and so a lot of the
complacency is built in the technology
and the integration of it has created a
world where I'm getting the chemical
benefit but I'm not actually getting the
tangible benefit yeah that was something
that freaked me out when uh huberman was
telling me that
um you know you get a dopamine hit just
from saying I'm gonna go work out right
now like you get a dopamine hit by going
hey I'm gonna go work out that you get a
dopamine hit right there and you don't
need to do anything else you get a
dopamine hit by by you know scanning one
more screen on your Instagram or uh
what's it called uh scroll scrolling one
more screen on your Instagram you get a
dopamine hit from each one of those you
get a dopamine hit from posting like you
just said you get a dopamine hit from
from talking about it you get a dopamine
hit from these little meaningless things
free dopamine it's free dopamine yeah
and you free dopamine that you don't
earn is freaking terrible for you I mean
how did we get our dopamine like we did
it yeah like with with no Intel by the
way it's like you just you just
propelled into it yeah I remember guys
that would when I was going through
basic seal Trend there was a couple guys
that went out with a few times and they
were telling people that they were in
Seal training and I was like that's
really weird like I felt like really
uncomfortable telling anybody that like
talking to girls yeah they're going
still training right now and I was like
that seems really weird and they got the
dopamine hit from that oh yeah they got
a little reward and it was good enough
for them and then they quit
you know that's man think about that on
a grand scale of Life yeah like these
little things that you say you're gonna
do and then you don't ever do them now
they're posting about it and just lying
that's really disturbing though the the
fact of hey where there's pressure in
the world where there's problems in the
world and your reaction is hey I don't
like these things I'm just going to go
back to this complete safe Zone that I
have control over which is my phone and
a bunch of people that are programming
algorithms to make me look at it more
it's crazy drawing you in it is a scary
world in that sense and I think when we
talk about resilience and preparedness
and all that a lot of this roots and the
start point of like what do you want to
be and if you want to be
um you know working through generative
machines and Ai and and and living a
virtual life you could do that and be
happy likely because you're getting the
same chemistry or you could put the
phone down and realize like I need to be
prepared for a tangible world most
people aren't prepared for a real world
I mean there's people who are literally
I mean 40 000 people a year in this this
country die in vehicle accidents and and
that's a real stat the increase based on
the the Baseline of 30 000 is because of
cell phone integration because I'm
distracted so how distracted are we
where I mean I feel guilty for last week
spending a lot of time on my phone
working because I had a lot of work and
I had my kids at the time and during
that time I'm like doing things they're
doing all these things and I'm not able
to bridge that Gap even though they're
in my life in my living room on the
ground I'm tied into another world an
alternate universe and it's like holy
crap just put that down reintegrate and
build that tangible reality I mean I I
we're doing a rewilding course but my
first version of this is in July
um it's already sold out so I apologize
if I'm putting that out there but it's a
it's Get Back To Nature and it it's
based on some of huberman's information
and there's a couple of people's
information that are important but most
certainly it's about the dopamine
because if I set the dopamine aside and
like he said saying I'm going to go to
the gym is dopamine so how much of our
Lives is he inoculated in dopamine our
entire life is we're we're not special
we're in very natural very Primal driven
animals and we want that dopamine but
now we have it at our disposal at any
time on our cell phone how do you get it
naturally it's very actually difficult
to get that naturally so when you unplug
technology and you put people into a
primal situation where now they have to
hear the sound of their tinnitus and
their ear because it's so damn quiet
that changes everything and it takes
about 48 Hours According to some guys
including human I believe to kind of
Disconnect from that and to kind of
reset your brain to get into a position
to go oh like this is another frequency
I'm operating on like the real world
frequency I'm not I don't have Bluetooth
sucking all of my resilience away
through my through my cell phone
yeah that's really just disturbing to
think that I don't know you and I are us
we didn't have that phone until how long
phones come out 20 years ago like 20
years ago you had a iPhone came out in
2007 right and that's really when people
started to get them I think the social
media part of it was it when the
integration of like uh reality and the
virtual like when you could take
pictures and send them to the phone
that's when it really took off that was
a bad time so that's all
at least we know what it's like not to
have that analog we're the we're the
last generation of analog Atari players
uh awesome all right great stuff I'm
glad this freaking
world's collapsing around we're gonna be
ready
uh you say this this next section is
about planning a society we've grown
comfortable without searching Our Lives
to their sake of convenience of the
faucet leaks we call a plumber if our
neighbor breaks our fence we call a
lawyer than a carpenter if our car
breaks down we call a mechanic then Uber
what about when catastrophe strikes you
need a plan you need to know how to make
a plan which means you need to
understand how to plan for contingencies
to not only line out how to respond in a
catastrophe efficiently and effectively
but also how to shift your actions and
adapt along the way the number one
characteristic common to all survivors
of catastrophe is adaptability and the
best course of action for becoming
adaptable is to have a plan for a series
of predetermined contingencies in your
back pocket
Special Operations at least a third of
the proposed timeline of every mission
is spent in the planning phase
when we plan we never plan for things to
go right instead we plan for things to
go wrong what I mean is we expect to
accomplish our objective but we never
expected the way we intended to
accomplish it will go off without a
hitch it's called Murphy's Law for a
reason in war or in a fight there are no
rules really and your opponent is never
going to make it easy on you they're
going to booby trap the most obvious
attack route and block the most obvious
Escape Route they aren't constrained or
limited by rule of law a scheduled
timeline or approval from up the chain
of command with flexibility and the
right motivation the enemy most
certainly is going to make your life a
living hell but it's not always an
adversary that creates these obstacles
it can be the elements or your lack of
equipment or your own biases and
preconceptions in chaos and uncertainty
these are the forces that often work
against you at the worst possible moment
whether you're at war with yourself
Mother Nature an angry mob you need to
be prepared to operate at the speed of
war and that requires a plan
and then you get into
uh how to start planning and one thing I
liked about is you go and again get the
book so you can actually go through and
get this knowledge
uh asking questions about your situation
is a great way to start figuring out
what your plan is going to be
you got a little hey honey what would
you do if a guy burst through our door
front door right now well I'd kick his
ass what if he has a gun I take cover
draw my pistol and defend our lives are
you carrying your gun right now no where
is it upstairs on the dresser like it
always is when we're at home do you
think you get it before he got me
uh and then you just go through like
legit questions how strong are door
locks is the path from the front door to
the kitchen too open is there a better
ideal place to store a firearm how could
we could we have better security
measures in place to give us an earlier
warning How likely is something like
this to happen based on where we live
and then you go through course of action
development
um you just start explaining how to come
up with a plan and again these are
principles that you and I and one
percent of the population of America has
a grip on has some knowledge of but
civilians don't have to do this
and that's why this is so powerful you
go into some details like if you live in
California Japan in cities with a couple
days Drive of the Himalayas or the
kinderhush you should definitely have a
good flashlight bottled water and
practice running into doorways or
ducking under desk why is that because
they are where earthquakes happen but if
you live in Florida or Scandinavia or
Malta you probably shouldn't waste all
your time or money prepping for the big
earthquake you'd be much better off
preparing for hurricanes or blizzards
and heat waves because those will happen
more frequently precisely where you live
so you go into these things
um and start to talk about the
priorities isn't possibly prepared for
everything and anything but it's very
possible to be prepared for everything
that has any real chance of happening
based on where you live
so
great information and so basic
so fundamental I don't call it basic but
it's fundamental to how you're going to
make good decisions and how you're going
to execute when something goes wrong
um you get into some of the details like
Pace plan you know primary alternate
contingency emergency
this is something you learned when you
were a freaking E4 you know
um
and yet there's a dad right now that's
taking his family camping
and he doesn't have a plan if his cell
phone dies
doesn't have a plan
you know what's he gonna use for
navigation I got GPS on my phone we'll
be good okay
what happens when you drop that thing in
the you know River while you're trying
to get a drink you don't have a map and
compass with you like those fundamental
things to Think Through are so important
when you deal with when you teach your
classes are people in awe of these are
they super like I would imagine if I
didn't know this stuff and you would
teach me like this is freaking awesome
people must be pumped they're super
pumped like if we take for granted for
example planning right when I was in the
Infantry when I was a private I went to
Ranger school and as an 18 year old
child I was briefing a Warner warno or
warning order for the first time to a
bunch of Green Berets infantry guys and
I'm like holy crap and being judged and
critique for it
when we think about the sexy things that
we did
the only reason we were able to do that
one sexy thing like hitting an objective
was because of all the things that we
paid attention to before that especially
the planning and I had a team start Rick
Wilson in third group and he was a great
guy but he wasn't known for like the war
fighter team Sergeant he was like the
admin team sorry you categorized like
dude
[Music]
he's a gunfighter but you got you had
like two versions of this like the
Garrison guy or like the combat guy that
still doesn't help bro come on give this
dude some love yeah he he's been in some
stuff he's been in some good gun fights
but when when Rick mentored my team as
his as the Zulu as the team sort I
remember him doing things that we hated
like he would say he would say hey man
um we're going to do a course of action
development planning session and
everybody's like what like yeah we're
gonna do mdmp military decision making
process and we would do the Whiteboard
like coas and we would do wargaming and
we would talk and we would strategize
and I think like if you made a
recruiting video for the Navy Seals and
it was the Navy uh seals making a a
Terrain model you know like pouring sand
for the MSR you know making you know
taking uh GI Joes and vehicles and
string them together nobody would join
everybody wants the sexy but the reason
those sexy things are successful are
because of the attention to detail and
planning and the most important thing
for planning that civilians take away is
the template
we have what I've realized in military
guys I say me you Andy Stumpf Evan Hafer
we have the structure built and
programmed in our heads so when you tell
me something you say hey here's the task
well that's the mission like that's the
goal that's the mission so I line up the
mission and before that I know the
acronym is Sergeant Major eats sugar
cookies which is situation Mission
execution server support command and
signal I know automatically okay what's
the situation and I analyze it I am
literally breaking down my entire life
and planning based on the template that
I was that I learned as a young
infantryman
so when you fast forward that what it
does for you is it gives you a way to
program in the most efficient and
effective way to be successful that
applies to I mean extreme ownership
talks about it this military way of
planning and shaping your life if it's
organized
um it's executable and that's the
important metric in all of this most
people buy the gun they go to the range
they shoot holes in paper they shoot the
bullets to the holes they created in
paper and they fall in love with
themselves and they think that's it I'm
prepped I'm prepared EDC hashtag what
they don't really do is go what the hell
do I do and the highest statistical
probability of a potential catastrophe
where I live like I always ask classes
in gunfighter pistol everybody here
wants to be a gunfighter like yeah
everybody they got their kit their sexy
guns multicam everything and I'm like
how many of you buy a show of hands have
a fire escape plan for your family no
hands like okay so you're here because
you want to get proficient in the gun
fight but what if I told you the fire
has a more statistical probability of
killing you which it does and they're
like uh oh maybe I should look at that
and make a plan like yeah maybe you
should like we're gonna do gunfighter
pistol it's gonna be great we're gonna
check that block but let's focus on the
basics and it starts with a conversation
which is not that complicated and by the
way like
me saying have a conversation
if I said that 10 years ago or 20 years
ago nobody everybody like yeah of course
you have a conversation like it's normal
now think about how many people have
conversations in their own home how many
people are willing to talk to their
spouse about anything besides what
they've checked the block on uh their
entire lives and and actually step
outside of that and say honey have you
ever thought about if we have a fire in
this home like uh we'll get to it later
right it's like nobody has conversations
anymore nobody knows their neighbor you
know like you don't even know your
neighbor and you're trying to build
um this preparedness mindset and and
these preparedness tactics but you don't
know your neighbor we need to do all of
these things and it starts with a basic
plan which is basically easy hey what's
cool about that too is uh a lot of times
I'll I'll work with companies and
they'll say like we want to do a team
building exercise I'm like cool hey what
do you do
like what's your job or a construction
business we're manufacturing you you
have team building exercise you live in
them so you want to do something cool
with your wife or your husband be like
hey you know what we can do Friday night
let's come up with a plan in case
there's a fire in this house and let's
come up with a primary alternate
contingency yeah emergency rehearse it
practice it together that's that's like
cool it's a little team building
exercise yeah date night
so I mean the difference between your
preparedness when you have a plan versus
you don't have a plan is infinite it's
just absolutely infinite so a great
place to start think about these
situations that you could get in and
come up with some kind of a basic plan
uh this next section of the book um I
think is one of the most important part
of the books
it's called arrogance and willful
ignorance are your enemy
I think the second chapter
um in the book extreme ownership is
check your ego
every good preparedness plan requires
good information you must know your
immediate surroundings and the larger
environment through which you will most
likely have to navigate you need to
understand your adversary whether it's a
single active shooter a mob of angry
protesters a pathogen or something like
a fire or freezing temperatures you need
to have a good grip on tools and
equipment you might be able to utilize
and you need to have an honest
accounting of what you can and cannot do
physically in terms of stamina and
strength and mentally in terms of tough
decisions with hard choices and
tactically in terms of skills and
abilities
those are some major major things out
there an honest accounting
this is the dude that's like well what
if someone attacks you they're like hey
when I see Red Bro yup just watch out I
can handle anything uh
[Music]
how far can you walk dude I can walk in
definitely oh really how far can you
walk with 40 pounds on your back a long
time how many miles I don't know well
you're right you don't know do you uh
that's a problem
it's a huge it's the biggest problem
that I run into in teaching civilians
especially The Gun Guys right
let me give a prime example
my basic pistol defensive course
I try I I do a methodology where it's
just train the trainer right I I'm I'm
doing peer-to-peer training I
communicate to my students like their
peers not their subordinates they're not
a group of ranger battalion privates
and so the methodology is different in
practice as well because I give them
context of why I Define all the why and
I want to give them the tools there's no
magic tricks in our Technical Training
when we get to the component where we
did basically four fundamentals of gun
fighting which are very different than
fundamentals of Marksmanship that their
home different and then we do shooting
and moving we culminate the entire day
with a culmination exercise known as a
stress shoot it's common stuff except
the methodology is hey I'm going to tell
you what what I'm doing I'm trying to
elicit a response from you that is
optimizing your performance so I want to
put them about 120 to 150 beats per
minute and that for the average male
with a Max BPM of about 195 takes about
five minutes of calisthenics On Any
Given environmental factored day snow
sleet heat it doesn't matter about five
minutes of calisthenics
and that puts them in the optimal
Windows to succeed
except if you show up and you're not the
Baseline my Baseline means your
cardiovascular fit your strength and
conditioning is reasonable and you have
good technical proficiency skills you
could execute this drill that I do and
shoot it flawlessly it's very easy to to
attain
except
most of the course about half to above
that
are not fit they're not cardiovascular
fit and five minutes of calisthenics
breaks them in half and as they're
moaning and groaning about three minutes
in about 120 beats per minute what I've
observed is the brain is telling the
body or the body in this case in turn is
telling the brain you're gonna die like
if you if you don't stop this you're
gonna die it's like you're doing jumping
jacks this is calisthenics it's push-ups
lunges air squats uh burpees and jumping
jacks and so I say do you have them do
one minute of each or something one
minute of each flexing into the next one
right out the gate and then I do a talk
through as I can make communicating to
them what is happening
and most often the response that
correlates to this is
if I say to these guys
you're a mile away from a half a mile
away from your kid's school you just
drop them off and there's an active
shooting at the school what are your
actions
and most of them will say 99 of
everybody I've asked this question will
say I get out of the car and I run as
fast as humanly possible
and I hit that front door and then like
what do you do then I I go after I go
find my kid or I kill the bad guy and
get my kid and then I say and you will
get your kid killed I'm like what do you
mean it was like based on what you just
told me like what do you mean well what
you just told me was emotionally driven
what do you mean it was mostly driven I
said I was going to run as fast as
possible yeah so what is run as fast as
possible mean it means you're going to
exert yourself physically
as much as you can because you think
that that's going to save your child and
it's not the balance is so your
condition responses you sh you move with
a purpose but at the pace in which you
could technically and proficiently shoot
move and communicate so if you're at 190
beats per minute because you ran as fast
as you could you hit the front door
you'll kill a lot of innocent people and
you'll never kill the bad guy you'll
likely get I hope you get killed I hope
your family member doesn't get killed I
hope you do in this sake because I don't
want you to live without regret for the
rest of your life and they can't they
don't comprehend this like guys
everybody wants to be a gunfighter but
nobody wants to slow down and understand
what this what we're talking about here
the Baseline line Foundation is physical
fitness health and wellness and if you
show up here with five thousand dollars
worth of gun and kit and you can't do a
minute of push-ups you need to go back
to your life and start over and they're
like well what do you mean at three
minutes I have grown men complaining
like uh grunting and I'm like guys
understand that's your central nervous
system telling your your mouth to say
something or do something so you can get
peer feedback so you can get that
dopamine hit because it feels like
you're running off the rails and you
need that dopamine to keep you on it and
they're like well and it's like
everybody's silent I want you to be
silent and I always get it about three
minutes in people start suffering and I
said I want you to suffer in silence and
then I get them I talk through I say I
want you to find your happy place
because if you don't find that
and you don't realize what's about to
happen that you're about to go to the
breach point and save your potential
child
then you won't make it and at the very
end about four minutes in when they're
breaking down which is crazy to say out
loud that after performance of
calisthenics but this is America this is
the the culture that we're living in at
about four minutes when everybody's kind
of like feeling sorry for themselves and
I say the word but it's like the in
burpees they know it's coming and
especially a bird and they're like oh I
was like all right you guys could have
that mindset but let me put it to you
this way if I told you your loved one
was in that room in that classroom your
child name ex-person that is your loved
one that you love and cherish most in
there would you still have that same
response or would you shut them up and
all of them are like oh and you could
see like when I tell them that their
loved ones In Harm's Way that emotional
side that barrier where they're they're
they're distracted because they're
brain's telling or their body's telling
their brain uh this isn't working out
it's like you don't you need to stop
you're gonna die they start to calm down
and they start to hone
what I've realized is through our
careers we've honed
they haven't honed at all because they
think it's all about the five thousand
dollar kit and gun that's what makes
them the experience is what makes them
it's learning and building resilience
through hardship and at the end of it
five minutes they shoot the drill when
they're done we assess like who shot
good who shot who didn't shoot good I
have guys who are like capable fit dudes
who technically suck they shoot like
crap I have guys who are not fit they
shoot like uh they shoot like crap
because they're cardiovascular unfit
I've had guys come back years later lost
a hundred plus pounds and go when you
called me out in five minutes of
calisthenics after I thought I was
squared away I realized I don't know
anything and I need to start over that
recognition that vulnerability I think
out of all the things that we do in in
this stuff that we're talking about is
most important because most civilians
don't have an institution peers or
people who love them that are going to
tell them how much they really suck
right we come from a culture where it's
like constantly it's like I was one of
my guys is here for for media uh John uh
one of my my uh personal assistant today
sent me a a video of an Asian community
being talking about
um he was talking about a love language
and he was getting affirmation he said
your love language is like Words of
Affirmation he's like I I have an Asian
mom like my words of affirmation was
like my love language like verbal abuse
because the person who loved me told me
you're not good enough you could be
better and we come from that culture
most people don't and the first time
they go through that they go
oh my God man this is life-changing I'm
like a five hour session on the flat
range was life-changing or I'll take it
but it it turns out to be just the
simple things can change lives like that
yeah that's the the fact that you can
just kind of go through life and no one
will ever say like hey bro
like
what's up you put out some palettes
he's still working out and they're
offended people people will sue over
stuff like that yeah that's terrible
terrible
um
that assessment that you do yourself
the honest part of that
it's so critical to sit there and think
like
you know I'd be able to do this if I had
to you know I'd be able to scale down my
three-story out my three-story window
because you know I could do it
you need to check yourself you know like
oh I'd be able to grab my three-year-old
and carry her down this ladder like
really have you drilled that
um
you're going to say the biggest enemies
of good planning are arrogance and
ignorance it's the foolish belief on the
one hand that you don't need a plan for
catastrophe because that will never
happen to me and it's the refusal on the
other hand to even consider planning for
Worse worst case scenario because you
don't like to think about how all the
bad things that can happen to you in
this world it's difficult to know which
of these is worse or more common
ignorance or arrogance because in the
end the result is the same it's the
difference between you having your head
in the sand or up your ass either way
you won't be able to see what's coming
or which way to go when it gets there
you talk about the arrogance on the in
the book about the Titanic and the
Titanic
um they just thought the ship couldn't
sink and so
you say here arrogance resulted in the
formulation of no meaningful evacuation
procedures no emergency response plans
and even less training on April 14 1912
the middle of the moonless night the
Titanic hit an iceberg and then the
hit the fan chain of command immediately
completely broke down the crew with
little sense of what to do or in what
order made some horrible decisions and
cost hundreds of lives one crew member
locked the third class passengers down
in the bowels of the ship until the
first class passengers could reach and
board the lifeboats other crew members
who were Manning those lifeboats then
only filled them to 60 to 70 percent
capacity because they weren't sure that
the cranes used to lower the lifeboats
into the water called davits could
support that much weight
they were worried that the davits would
collapse and the lifeboats would tumble
in the sea they were worried because
they'd had little to no Lifeboat
training
and they hadn't been told by management
that the davits had been successfully
tested at maximum capacity back in Port
results total catastrophe of the 2224
people aboard the Titanic only 706
survived
um
as dangerous as it is to rely entirely
on infrastructure of society to protect
and provide for you living in denial
about the randomness of Misfortune and
be willing and being willing willfully
ignorant about the possibility that
someday you might have to protect and
provide for yourself is courting
disaster
we all know who people who live like
this they don't believe bad things could
ever happen to them like arrogant people
do but they believe or maybe a better
word is hope that they can insulate
themselves from Bad Things by
eliminating as much risk as from their
lives as possible remember hope is never
a course of action these are freaking
societal checks that need to go down
um
as important as proper fast forward a
little bit as important as proper
planning as to a fully prepared life
there are some things you just can't
plan for there's no Pace plan for
unforeseeable but what you can do is
embed the principles of pace planning
into how you walk through the world
there's something magical about planning
that doesn't have anything to do with
the plan itself but what you learn in
the process of making a plan
every building you enter every room you
step into you can casually note where
all the exits are which one's a closet
which one gets you outside the fastest
are there Windows do they open if you
want to take that little further look at
your phone and see that the what the
cell service is like are there fire
extinguishers nearby what about a
defibrillator
with a little bit of training and
practice you can do this kind of room
and scan for your own makeshift Pace
plan in less than 30 seconds this
reminds me of always telling guys you
know out on patrol
when you're doing immediate action
drills like you should be no it doesn't
matter if you're the leader or not you
should as you're walking be like oh I
forget contacted from front right now we
can do this I got a little little null
over that a little building I can get
into over there we can probably hit a
center peel here or a peel right over
there or a shift right over there and
you're doing that and it changes every
15 Steps that you take you're like
coming up with your next plan but damn
you seem like a freaking genius when the
contact comes and you automatically know
what to do because you've already had in
your head you don't even have to assess
anything
so that sort of uh
it's almost like just existing in a
constant state of planning and I don't
want to get crazy here
but why not why not when you walk into a
building be like cool there's an
accident over there yeah hey there's
another emergency accident back kind of
look in the kitchen you can see that
there's an exit usually in the kitchen
like okay we've got some things going on
here like why not do that
I do it in every instance in every
environment that I go into and people
who don't understand it will think
you're paranoid but I think I'm very
deliberate and I'm living an offensive
prepared life that's very different in
mindset because when you want to be
complacent because you think complacency
means freedom it's the complete opposite
because what you're doing is you're
setting setting yourself up for failure
and I you know the the the the
culture that we came from
the lowest man needed to know the plan
understand their role and their mission
if they had to step up and take lead
that that is a beautiful thing and part
of all the things that we're talking
about in in this section have to do with
the idea that it's not just getting
information fed to you like we we have
this relationship with Society because
we pay taxes and we think building
efficiency and institutional Outsourcing
and models is going to build that
efficiency so if I say I've outsourced
my education because it doesn't make
sense for me to educate because I gotta
work I've outsourced my security because
police officers and firefighters I pay
the taxes they respond to me I don't
need to know that we've outsourced
ourselves into complacency so if I
understand all the mechanisms of the job
and the role and the thing because I'm
part of the process I am so much more
prepared I realize just when we had to
do it was called um
I don't know if the Navy used the same
term you ever heard the term ISO fact
yes ISO facility the first time I got
told hey we got a mission you're gonna
go to the iso fact for a week and you're
gonna plan I'm like what how can you
possibly plan for a week and like you
can plan for a week right you go into
the iso fact there's no guns there's
nothing cool there's white boards and
there's there's terrain sketch models
there's mapping there's S2 guys running
around in the Intel and you're working
out all the details of that plan what I
realized in those moments in the iso
fact it wasn't about the actual plan as
disseminated it was about the process
and being part of it and then when you
were part of it you understood it in its
totality so when something did go wrong
you knew in your head you weren't just a
machine gunner on a weapon system you
understood what was going on that is so
important in civilian life because it's
it's about extreme ownership you don't
have any ownership when you've
outsourced everything institutionally
and you're floating around thinking
everything's perfect until the dude in
Allen Texas steps out of a vehicle with
a AR-15 and starts killing people in
front of you and then you're like I hope
I get through this like hope is not a
course of action I hope that when
something like this potentially does
happen to you
that you get lucky I hope you get lucky
but to lean and depend on luck is is
problematic to say the least yeah this
this idea of situational awareness and
of looking you know when you walk into a
room or walk into a building you walk
into a restaurant you walk into a store
you take that
15 seconds this costs you nothing this
costs you nothing into your reaction
time is going to be so much faster than
your reaction time if you if you walk
into a restaurant you're like hey let's
pretty good cover over pretty good
covering concealment over in this area
over there cool I know I can get there I
can get out that window really quickly
look there's an open door back there
your reaction time is like gonna be
almost instantaneous as opposed to a
active shooter walks in there and starts
shooting people you don't even know what
to do now you're trying to look around
while you're trying to take cover at the
same time and it's just a total disaster
it's a total disaster
and when you're proactively thinking
about these things it's just making you
more situationally aware
in in the first place I mean this is
just how you become aware of what's
happening around you as opposed to you
walk in and you're just uh scrolling
through your social media and looking at
this thing without assessing anything
that's going on it's freaking terrible
yeah you're more you're conscious and
you're plugged into what's going on
around you you're you're simply focused
You're simply paying attention let's
even break it down even more just pay
attention and most people don't my
daughter just discovered I got her this
pink iPad she's three and a half years
old and the for the first time I
realized that she's glued to it right
she's YouTube for kids right she's doing
I I've Source her content and say hey
this is what you're watching right and I
don't pay attention to her she pays
attention to it the other day I was
trying to walk her from the first floor
to the second floor so going up a little
bit of stairs and she was falling all
over the place and then would instead of
getting up and putting the iPad had down
and like walking and looking the stairs
because she was so focused on and intent
intently focused on the actual iPad she
kept picking it up kept looking at it
and walking up the stairs and fumbling
and falling our entire Society is that
ours that that figurative analogy our
entire Society is a three and a half
year old walking upstairs staring at
their phone right trying to walk
upstairs it impossible and even when
they fall it doesn't stop them it
doesn't stop them so so now when you
look at like the basic understanding of
situation awareness and just paying
attention to your environment
um most people can't do it because
they're addicted to their cell phone or
they're addicted to diverting their
attention because the algorithm has
pulled their attention away and they
don't realize it so I'm just asking for
people read the words read the book and
then pay attention to the environments
that you're in because like you said it
now no longer becomes self-defense if
I'm offensively and openly and overtly
analyzing and assessing my situation so
all I have to do is pay attention in
that environment I'm staged and prepared
for anything that potentially kicks off
a guy just asked me this because he was
in Allen Texas when this outlet mall
shooter went in killed eight people
injured 11. and when he went in as soon
as he got out of the vehicle he started
dumping people I mean most of everybody
was killed was killed on the initial
contact the police officer responded
responded within minutes and winded up
saving a lot of people because he had a
laugh a lot of ammo left
so when he started to engage with people
one of the guys asked me if I'm walking
with my family in that situation because
he was with by himself if I'm walking
with my family in that situation what
could I do if I was in that situation
and I said there's not much you could do
in that particular instance but it all
comes down to your behavior what are you
doing at that moment most people in that
moment were complacently not paying
attention because why would they they're
in America where freedom and democracy
and all these good things allows us the
ability to be complacent if you're
driving in Libya or the Middle East and
you're looking at your phone you'll just
die because a dude will T-Bone you with
a donkey cart you know you'll be dead
but everybody there pays attention well
if you're paying attention and you
recognize things that are anomalies
which we talk about in the book which is
the spike in the pattern and you see the
guy pull up and get out of his vehicle
and you have a fanny pack on and it's
staged properly because I carry a fanny
pack my company's fanny pack that I
design that has pistol access which I
could draw as quickly as I can removing
my shirt in appendix carry why do I care
that because I'm a dad and fanny packs
are cool for dads and I carry my first
aid in the same pack but if I saw that
vehicle come up and I'm staged properly
it would take me half a second to
recognize it in about 1.25 seconds to
draw that pistol and be on target
potentially so there's a time and place
based on my environment but I'm always
thinking about the Tactical advantage on
the up offensive and paying attention if
you're on the back side of that you're
just reacting and you're too slow we all
know the the the reaction versus action
you're just too slow yeah same scenario
if you're walking with your kids at the
mall
and you did this is free and it's
actually I don't know maybe maybe we're
just weird but
we're weird
get weird then because if you're walking
and you're like hey um hey I'm walking
down the street
was there's an active shooter right now
oh there's some uh planners over there
there's a some planners those are really
good cover I got my two kids with me I'm
literally gonna toss them over those if
we can attack them they'll toss them
over there this is this is just like
internal conversation that you can have
at any time and it's actually really
good because if you're thinking oh
there's some boardwalking to the right
to our right of some planners in the
parking lots over there we get contacted
got some cover and concealment that's
cool no big deal you're not it's not
costing anything right you know you can
still be carrying our conversation with
you I have those internal dialogues
while I'm carrying on conversations all
the time right that's weird I do that
same thing but yeah but it's it's it's
necessary it is and it's good training
for yourself and look you know do you
want to tell your kids that depends on
how old they are or whatever but if
you're walking you're like hey there's
some planners to our right right now if
we got contacted from over there we're
getting Behind These planners now as
soon as that guy gets out and you see
how happen you're in cover you're not
thinking about anything you're like oh
we have an active situation and I'm
going to take cover my kids are
protected and and like you said in a
half a second we're done we're we're if
you're not thinking about if you're
looking at your phone and all of a
sudden you hear shots fired because
you're not paying attention now you're
potentially getting killed your kids are
getting killed because you're not paying
attention what's going on you don't have
any freaking plan whatsoever you you
walk down the street enough times and
think like that you're gonna become
mentally proactive as to what's
happening and you're going to be a jump
ahead by five seconds seven seconds ten
seconds if you decide to just lock up
and not you know freeze up like you
talked about earlier so that situational
awareness
so important and it's something that you
can habitually do it's kind of fun
I mean I guess I don't know I guess
that's just what we're gonna naturally
do I mean I guess like a skateboarder
walks down the street and says like oh
that'd be a cool freaking curb to hit
and I'd be like cool stairs to jump off
of I get that too I do that too but I
think as I got older it was more like
hey there's good covering seal there's a
good shooting position there's like
let's think of there's a there's an
egress route over there like think about
those things because that's doesn't cost
you anything it's just situational
awareness it's you might think I'm crazy
but you're freaking crazy sitting there
staring at your phone as you're walking
down the street with your kids you're
freaking crazy
so get some situational awareness
oh yeah you got a whole section in here
um we just covered a bunch of it um
you even talk about you know you get
technical about how to scan what you did
to scan by grid you mentioned that stuff
in here you also called uh Andy Stumpf
and Evan Haye for two brilliant Hunters
my book's now fiction yeah which I
freaking had to open up a text that I
don't with those guys last night that
was freaking awesome there was some
really good comments we could probably
publish that whole text there because it
was freaking hilarious
um but you know you do you get into the
details of how to do those things you
talk about Five and Twenty fives like
the protocols for checking before you
get out of your vehicle again hey man
look if you if if you're gonna call me
paranoid or call you paranoid for
behaving like this because it was a
detriment to some other part of your
life if it was like you you know your
kids are like Hey Dad
um look at the tree over there and
you're like hey quiet I'm doing my fives
and 25s like if then I could see people
being negative or you're like
um hey Daddy can we go get some ice
cream and you're like negative there's
no cover or concealment in that area if
we're talking about that I can
understand people saying hey man you
need to chill out a little bit I get it
but this is like all just good common
internal
um planning that you can do assessment
of the situation that you're in and it's
there's no detracting to it whatsoever
there's none there's no there's no
negative impact of this at all it's not
making you pay less attention to your
kids at all these are things that you
can do without while you're carrying on
a conversation these are things that are
take no very limited extra brain power
in fact it's the what is it you only use
10 of your brain anyway so why not use
at least three percent of it to find out
where there's good covering containment
as you're walking down the street
it's freaking straightforward same thing
you go into in here talking about
identifying people watching people you
say when you take a second to look at
the entire list of potential IED
indicators enumerated
from the Marines fsmo course of
instruction what you notice is just as
frequently as they mentioned things that
stand out
they mentioned people that stand out
people in places they normally wouldn't
be people not in places they normally
would be people doing things that not
anyone else is doing people doing things
that they shouldn't be doing
so you talk about how to look for those
things and this is the thing these are
things that
anybody this takes you know you talk
about some training that you went
through anybody that pays attention will
notice this stuff you'd be like hey wait
a second everyone's sitting here uh you
know in the traffic stop and everyone's
looking at their phones you got one
person that's like walking in a very
direct manner of course like
pay attention to that everybody can see
that if they're watching
um you talk about hands and and demeanor
you've got to watch the hands this is
something you and I have heard a
thousand times and then you close it up
by saying in simplest terms your
situational awareness and the prospect
of your safety are determined by how
well you combined surveillance of your
immediate surroundings with a scan of
the people in that environment to limit
the cognitive load of doing unique
location-specific deep surveillance
every time you enter new space there's a
simple approach you can use that works
99 of situations every time you enter a
new unfamiliar uncomfortable or
potentially dangerous space let's use a
restaurant and a Suburban Mall as an
example first get your bearings in the
environment where the exits what is the
most direct path through those exits do
does the place look clean do the tables
and chairs look as if they're in good
condition does the place feel safe these
are just things that you can do to be
freaking ready
next section this is another thing that
he's just human beings gotta watch out
for denial is the biggest threat whether
or not to take action in the face of
imminent danger might seem like a
no-brainer
it would certainly seem like the single
most important factor in determining
your survival in a catastrophe but the
reality is the bigger issue is whether
or not you even accept the presence of
imminent danger at all
it sounds absurd that when faced with a
grievous threat to your safety you might
deny its existence except almost
everyone does it it's practically a
cultural script we hear a window shadow
that shattered downstairs in the middle
of the night we feel the ground
violently shake and see the chandelier
swinging wildly from the ceiling we hear
gunshots ring out from the office down
the hall
and what's the first thing we do when
something like that spikes the pattern
we come up with some ridiculous
explanation for it that dismisses any
possibility of true Danger
that's bizarre right it's a bizarre
human reaction I I think it's actually I
I think it's closer to laziness than I
think it's a psychological effect I mean
for people in context trying to
understand what this is is imagine
you're like watching Netflix
and you're watching your favorite TV
show so you're in it you're like oh this
is this is awesome I want to watch this
anything that happens you're upstairs
you're watching this show and you hear a
noise downstairs what's your reaction
most people hear that and they write it
off because they're like oh no no that's
just the that's just the cat like honey
we don't have a cat like oh oh well it's
I'm sure it's just something that fell
out it's like nothing happens
without something happening like it's
something you heard that because you
need to potentially check it out and so
even in my own life and pattern I've had
to set up an immediate action drill to
say
whether or not I like it I'm getting up
to check it out and that is going to be
my immediate action and that mindset is
hard for even me to get through because
I'm like this is a good show I got
bourbon like I got my show Yellowstone
and it's like I I'm here in this moment
and anything that pulls us away from
that is inconvenient and I think that's
a problem with this is denial is not
convenient for us and we want everything
to be convenient I imagine when the
active shooter who became a mass killer
the 22nd of the of of this year by the
way on an average of 24 mass killings a
year which is four or more people killed
not to be confused with mass shooting
um when that 20-second shooter got out
of his vehicle and he started shooting
likely there are people who witnessed
that and stared for a period of time
in denial
not realizing what they were seeing was
real because their brain was telling
them otherwise and that's a problem more
of a problem in a in a world immersed in
technology where everything's a game
everything's virtual everything's fake I
got a POV perspective of playing that
game in my mind this is just part of
that game no it's real and those bullets
that are coming out of that gun will
kill you and that reality for many
people who have never faced that kind of
reality
um sometimes it's too too too late you
know by time they do react when you need
those actions immediately to survive
it's too late
this goes back to what your mindset is
as you're walking
down through the mall you know if your
mindset is you're in la la land and
something like that presents itself if
you're in la la land it takes you four
seconds to get out of la la land or six
seconds to get out of la la land or 30
seconds to get out of la la land before
you actually do anything
three seconds of saying what the heck is
that you know six seconds of is it
Halloween right now is this guy doing is
this oh is this the cops doing some kind
of a display like all those little
thoughts instead of being
cognizant of the fact that this is the
world bad things can happen if you have
that mindset as you walk down the street
if you take one person and say hey this
is if if I took one person and primed
him and said hey this is a this is the
world and bad things happen walk down
the street that guy sees an active
shooter he's going to react faster than
someone I say hey isn't it a nice day
out today
that person's gonna have
a hesitation before converting reality
into reality
so that mindset that people have
got to think about
next section here is about decision
points it's called decision Point what
are you going to do
that is the question everything up to
this point has been about preparing you
for the moment when you have to answer
it forging resilience making plans
building situational awareness these are
the mental tools designed to cultivate
quick decision making and help you to
take the correct actions when
catastrophe strikes when the thing that
you are most terrified of that has
brought you on this journey to
preparedness has come to pass because
when your worst nightmare has been made
real and you need to flee or fight to
survive stress will be high and time
will be short you won't have the luxury
of contemplation of second guessing of
wait and see you'll have to act to go to
move to hide shoot to kill if that's
what it takes to keep you and your loved
ones safe
now this is the idea you have to think
quickly and make snap decisions in an
emergency probably doesn't sound
revolutionary you're probably thinking
yeah Mike no except it's never that
simple most people struggle with
decision making
so you go into this
um and
you
what you talk about in this um you talk
about the fact that people are making
decisions all the time and that people
are actually good at making decisions
like everything that you do in life is a
decision you talk about a guy that was a
wrestler and
what made him a good wrestler was he got
told listen everything you do in
wrestling is a decision that you're
making you just need to chain those
decisions together and that's how you
win
and so you talk about that in
the in terms of survival and pressure
situations
um
I wrote a book called leadership
strategy and tactics and I talk about
something that I did I was known as
being decisive in my career in sales
teams like if something was happening I
would make a decision let's make it
pretty quick
I was not gonna freeze I was gonna be
like hey we need to get over there we
need to move there
so I had a good reputation of being
decisive
but I cheated I always cheated I was a
cheater
two reasons why I was cheating number
one I was already thinking about what
we're gonna do if something happened so
that's cheating the other thing when I
would make a decision I would make a
very small decision very quickly
and then I would get the feedback of how
that decision went and I make another
small decision very quickly so as one
person one leader may look at a scenario
that's unfolding and think how can I
solve this whole thing I would look at a
scenario that's unfolding and say what
can I do right now that's going to
improve our position a little bit and
I'll do that thing
and guess what you improve that position
a little bit you're in a totally
different spot than you were 30 seconds
ago before you strong pointed a building
or before you maneuvered behind a berm
or whatever the case may be making those
small decisions quickly
that iterative decision-making process
is how you can become decisive and
that's the same thing that you're
talking about here making small
decisions quickly and then
applying the feedback because you're
going to get feedback off of your
decisions and then you got to apply that
feedback oh yeah that seems like a good
move wait a strong point of this
building now this building is getting
this building's starting to burn cool
what's my next decision gonna get out of
this building and go somewhere else so
that iterative decision making is what
you're talking about this book and it is
something that you can get better at
absolutely I think when you when you say
um decision making I think often of
adaptation right and the number one
characteristic in all survival
circumstances which have to do with
catastrophe or disaster is the ability
to make rapid decisions or adapt on the
Fly fluidly most people don't realize
that's an analytical and trainable
component to preparedness they don't
realize hey hey you know the one
survival psychologist John Leach who
focused on the study of why people live
and why people die when he assessed and
analyze all the information what he
broke down the population it was 10 80
10 10 survive 80 or somewhere in the
middle good or bad or indifferent they
make decisions some don't and then 10
are at the bottom of the barrel the goal
here is to put you in the top 10 percent
and the top 10 percent are good at
making decisions they don't have to be
operators they could be teachers they
could be mechanics they could be leaders
managers they're people who are used to
making decisions under stress uh rapidly
and fluidly and I think that's one of
the things that we neglect is how simple
this can be where you're trying to work
yourself through a difficult
circumstance you don't need a tool of
you don't need a bag of tools you just
need the ability to go hey maybe I need
to think creativity or creatively
through this circumstance instead of
analytically all the time and say hey
this isn't the best option maybe I could
do this that ability is something that
needs to be trained and honed we
actually teach a class called personal
security where we teach this and what
I've realized in decision Point
specifically most people don't know like
for example deadly force if I said to
most people what's your criteria to use
deadly force meaning to make a decision
to kill somebody because that's what
we're talking about the person would
likely give me legal jargon they would
recite something from the concealed
carry class they'd say well based on the
threat if they were threatening my life
or somebody else in this life that I
love or bodily harm I would use deadly
force like okay that's the book answer
but let's talk about what is your
personal ethical and moral compass
telling you and what is the criteria
well if a guy has a gun okay well the
guy has a gun and he's holding it by his
side and looks at you and says I love
you man you're gonna shoot him in the
face uh no well then what's your
criteria well if the guy pulls the gun
and lists it on me so if I look I lift
the gun and point it at you and you you
identify that gun you're going to shoot
and kill the person well just tell me
and what I do is I ask the question and
people feel the pressure and they're
like well well I'm like I'm just asking
the question because what you're
realizing with me in real time is you've
never thought about it like you've never
actually thought about when you would
actually use deadly force in a situation
and use the decision point to make the
decision that's going to change your
life forever
when I take the the coolest thing that I
do out of all the things I do is
scenario Based training and when I do
scenario-based training I can have five
people from five different walks of life
stand up and I walked in through a
scenario hey guys you're at an Airbnb
somebody walks in and you see the
outline of a gun if you decide to use
deadly force simply sit down and that's
your commitment to making the decision
to take a human life they sit down one
person sits down and then the guy walks
towards your family who's in a closed
room another person sits down and then
the person gets in the room and they
have a gun another person sits down and
then they get in front of your child
they're holding a gun over your child
another person sits down and then they
hold the gun to your child's head
and then they go to put the finger on
the trigger and then they go to press it
and the person's still standing
and then I'm like what the hell and then
the person shoots right next to your
daughter's head
and then they sit down I'm like well God
well what that's demonstrated across the
walk and spectrum of life is people have
different experiences triggers and
Trauma different training and every
single person has a different uh answer
for when they would use deadly force
from the person who's nearly the
conscientious objector who's like I'm
not going to shoot and kill anybody to
the person who's like that person
stepped afoot my door I'm killing him
when he's on my front porch right you go
to my rural Montana and I ask that same
question it's like there's a dark
shadowy everybody I'm like guys I
haven't even told you it could be your
wife it could be like I haven't
identified who the guy is but that just
tells us that this answer or this this
understanding of the use of deadly force
is varies by experience because in
civilian life there's not an institution
teaching us the rules of escalation and
protocol like if you're a police officer
it's very narrow it like you're like
when the person raises the gun towards
me and they're Potential Threat I will
take that that life as a civilian it's
completely different castle doctrine
stand your ground all these hybrid legal
theories apply and that's important to
delineate for a civilian who's like oh
yeah I I just kill bad guys with guns
well if they don't have a gun what if
they're beat what if they're smashing
your wife's head off the concrete you're
gonna do it then well you better be
prepared to answer that
disseminate that information how you
logically and reasonably came to that
conclusion and communicate that to a law
enforcement officer 10 minutes after you
just took a human life like let's
navigate all those things together
because that's how the works
the the scenario that you talk through
in the book like that which is awesome I
was enjoying reading it you know the the
Airbnb type thing and you see this turns
out to be a kid from next door that
wanted to return the Nerf gun it's like
okay you go through that so you gotta
talk through those
uh sort of theoretical
and then what you have to do is put a
simunition gun in someone's hand and put
them in that situation and it's freaking
Mayhem it's total chaos I remember a few
years ago they had a like they took some
guy that was uh against the police
basically saying the police were out of
control and they gave him this
ammunition thing you remember this one
yeah I do remember he killed everybody
yeah he killed everybody his whole he
was just murdering everyone yeah after
he came out he's like I need to shut my
mouth like this changed my life like and
and that's by the way that whole force
on Force training that we started doing
it wasn't very popular in the beginning
of the G wat I think likely because we
were busy working but as we started to
evolve in in the modern global war on
terror we started realizing what was
different than the schoolhouse right you
enter a point of domination you point
your gun you identify the threat hands
demeanor it's a paper Target you raise
your gun you find a red dot you break
shots that that process which I call the
shot process sometimes takes too long if
there's a guy like depicted in the
picture of the paper Target is holding
an AK-47 pointing at your head and you
step in that corner and you identify as
soon as you identify you need to be
breaking shots in the direction of that
that whole mechanism of raising my gun
aligning on the threat is completely
different than we actually did in the
schoolhouse which is if I throw a shot
I'm kicked out of this I'm not going to
take this risk versus I have the barrel
oriented in line in the point of
domination I haven't even found my Red
Dot the the infrared laser I don't even
recognize I just know it's a blur of
mass behind behind it and I've been in
those situations very specifically and
found that there's a difference between
the flat range and shooting paper and
still that don't react and taking a Sim
gun and doing it for real last class
Leah Stumpf uh Andy's wife who's a black
belt in Jiu Jitsu who's a former park
ranger great great uh woman she's
helping us with a lot of things related
to teaching women and children
when she she had to go through this
course because we make our own
instructors go through our own training
before they can ai ai me or assistant
instruct me
she was in a situation where we put her
and another guy inside of a vehicle and
they're inside of a UTV and in this
scenario there's a bad guy and the bad
guy comes up and I say bad guy because I
always say he's a bad guy but you assume
the guy is bad with malice intent or is
he because he could be a good guy I just
say bad guy as they walk up
this guy's rummaging through their
vehicle hey man you guys get money and
Lee is so nice she's like hey man relax
like what do you need what do you need
and she's trying to de-escalate
and it gets to the point where this guy
becomes aggressive and then the guy
who's the husband of Leah in this
scenario who's a student says something
off put to the guy
as per the Playbook the guy backs up and
he's like man screw you guys and he
turns around
Leah literally thinks in the AR uh she
communicates this but she literally
thinks in the moment man we de-escalated
that scenario we did a good job she's
already thinking like
check out because this is this is how it
went we did a good job he turns around
and in his de-escalation they reduce
their posture he draws the pistol and
turns and he breaks one shot before Leah
could recognize it Leah who's super fast
draws her pistol and actually gets three
shots off on the guy and and has barely
trained the firearm by the way draws his
pistol shoots this guy three three times
and when the scenario is done we
actually got this on camera
her face is locked in position and she's
sitting there staring with a firearm
holding the firearm with locked into
shock and not Shock like a bad way but
like shock like she's Frozen and I'm
like okay in the index in a scenario and
she's like oh my God I'm like Leah what
do you think can we do AAR afterwards
she's like I don't remember drawing the
gun I don't remember everything that
took place the only thing I remember is
man we did a good job we de-escalated
this guy was nice he went away and then
all of a sudden there's a gun I was like
how do you feel she goes the difference
between me understanding it and now
doing it is night and day because now I
understand all the Technical Training
all the things I've learned
don't apply to what is taking place
right now which is rapid decision making
under stress and until you've done force
on force or simunition space training
you don't realize that and I'm afraid
most of the guys that I trade on flat
ranges with guns haven't had that
experience and when we do put them in
those experiences they're the guys who
are really quick to the draw and
sometimes it's a bad shoot I mean we
have a scenario where a guy draws he
reaches down and he's drunk and
belligerent and he's reaching his pocket
they draw pistols and they're like show
me your hands it's like dude you're not
a cop but okay let's go through the
scenario and he pulls something out real
quick and it's a cell phone and they
smoke them and I've had guys go yeah you
know I had to put them down blah blah
it's like so what kind of gun do you
have oh yeah you know Glock 19 like oh
really all right show them your Glock
19. and it's like a Samsung phone like
oh like do you even remember that I had
no clue I thought I had a Glock 19. like
that that Gap needs to be filled we do
yeah at Echelon front we do role playing
with our clients right so we'll just
leadership role play like uh you know
okay Mike you're you got to get me to do
better accountability with my paperwork
and you walk in and you're like hey
jonker you know I notice your your
paperwork's not doing really you haven't
really been turning in on time and I'm
like you know what that stuff's a waste
of my time right and so then how do you
talk through that and the first time you
do it you'll suck and if echo's over
here watching we'll debrief it Echo do
it he'll be like five times better just
in one Evolution yep and then you'll do
it again you'll be 10 times better than
your first time the same thing happens
with this like you go through those
scenarios you get so much better each
time you do it we made a really big
transition when I first got in probably
when you first got into we were just
live fire everything yeah everything was
life right it's live fire live fire live
fire we were freaking awesome at live
fire
but
man those paper targets don't move they
don't shoot back and that's what the
enemy does in fact that's the threat
from the enemy is that they move and
they shoot back that's the freaking
problem right so as soon as we started
getting
the simunition man it was such a
freaking awesome awesome game changer
and that's how we would you know when I
talked about the stress the stress of
going into the kill house in 1995 when
you're like hey hey Glover you freaking
threw a shot you know you're like oh you
better not throw another shot you know
like that's the kind of pressure it's a
certain kind of pressure it's a certain
kind of stress right the stress of
you're going in and you're staring at
someone that's like please don't shoot
me please don't shoot me that's a
totally different kind of stress they
both provide benefit
but there's a different inoculation that
you get from one and the other you need
to get both you need to get both and I
think the one that we missed out on in
the 90s was the combat stress of Mayhem
and chaos and decision making really
rapidly I had a guy we were hitting a
Target and we found a freaking ID that
was like set in the perfect position to
blow up the salt Force you know like
outside the door stacked along the wall
there's an IED we we hit it without them
knowing you know we got in there and
then I'm like leave the assault I'm
walking outside and there's a freaking
guy comes walking up he's walking down
the street carrying a box and you know
my
Gunner is like starts blazing him the
guy kind of keeps walking
interpreter starts yelling or whatever
so then I go I go hold you know hold on
I'm going to get him and I start moving
towards him and I tell my chirp him I
got a turp like over my shoulder and I'm
like tell him to put that freaking box
down so the guy like bends down puts
puts the box down
so I walk so now I approach him and as I
get to him his hands are in his pockets
I'm like tell him to show him his hands
show his hands he pulls out his hands
he's got a remote control in his hands
and I'm like now I have his caller I
have his shirt because I'm about to put
him down
and so that's how close I am to him and
I with my gun I freaking hit that remote
control like it was easier than shooting
him like the quickest thing I could do
is get that remote control out of his
hand I hit that thing out of his hand I
dropped the dude I don't shoot him but I
Dr I get control of him knocking down
and and um you know just get control of
the situation
and I'm like talking to Turf I zip tie
him and everything and then I kind of
like go back to being I'm the assault
Force Commander right so I'm kind of
like okay let me go handle my so
another seal comes over they start
wrapping them up
um and I think you know this guy was
walking into freaking bomb us and I just
got lucky so it turns out the dude's
drunk and he had been over at his
buddy's house in the Box was a videotape
machine and he used it over there
watching porn
and yeah I almost freaking smoked and he
had a remote I had a remote in his
pocket yep had a remote in his pocket
and the reason I didn't shoot him is
because I was so close to him that it
was quick the instinct to do was to get
that remote out of his hand so he didn't
pull us up that's what I thought he was
going to do
um and so I just knocked it out his hand
and then I I mean I could have shot him
but I didn't
but those kind of things because we've
done so many like drills and so much
simunition and so much close contact you
do those things over and over and over
again you get you you get better at
making these decisions and you know
Leah's a stud like you know just the
fact like you say like Leah did this
good thing that's freaking outstanding
right getting three rounds off quick
draw for the guy that fires back and he
he goes from a de-escalated situation
immediately back into a deadly force
escalation that's a that's a freaking
tough decision to make
but like Lee is a jiu jitsu black belt
like she's used to stress and problems
not not as useless to as she is now
she's getting better and better like you
do that drill with her five more times
she's paying attention to different
things yeah like she'll never let her
guard down again when somebody's still a
threat that person's still a threat just
because they during their back on you
doesn't mean they're not a threat she
learned that lesson she learned it like
almost Written in Blood yeah almost
Written in Blood yep and that's where
you make improvements we got so much
better once we started using simulation
and then on the in the desert Warfare
scenarios we had like a laser tag system
that was awesome way better than Miles
no offense miles but it was way better
than Miles and the same thing like you
would see guys just be able to work and
make decisions very quickly but the
point of all that I'm trying to say
right now is you can get better at this
stuff you who's listening to this right
now
and and by the way the arrogance and
ignorance that you think dude I wouldn't
let that happen yes you don't know hey
sure you might be the one percent of the
population that's just super cool and
makes awesome decisions all the time you
might be that person even freaking Mike
Glover first time getting hit with a 107
millimeter was a little bit locked up
for three to six seconds a guy that had
been through Ranger school been through
SF training done a bunch of live fire
so if that can happen to him and you
think because you got a cool attitude
you're gonna be good to go like it ain't
happening you have to freaking train to
get better that's what you have to do
um
you mentioned me in this book so that's
cool I appreciate it which one where did
I mention uh former Navy SEAL Jocko oh
yes talked about
that's a good example though I mean it's
a perfect example it is where I think
the most impactful thing about that
statement which is you talking about hey
the best way to kind of de-escalate is
like like run like you could have the
confrontation and you can get sued you
can potentially get killed or you could
just go the opposite direction and I
think it's impactful because when you
have a when you have capability it's
like a it's like a martial art uh staple
you learn martial art because you you
know you're learning a a skill set that
could potentially be uh lethal
that is valuable but you also have to be
very responsible with that skill set
right we just did this event and I was
telling these people is that the muster
so at the muster we do yeah like a
knight of Jiu Jitsu at the end
so we're teaching so we teach like
literally just teach them what
jiu-jitsuas and so I talked about the
Americana arm like I'm like listen when
you do this you got to do it really slow
these are people that have never trained
before yeah like we gotta do this really
slow
if you if you go too hard you will wreck
your partner's shoulder they will never
be the same so please be very very
careful when you just do this personally
okay cool everyone's like I go cool then
we said you know I'm like Echo let's
teach something else and so let's teach
weird naked joke so we usually do that
and so then I say Hey listen so we're
about to teach you something that if you
do this you will you can kill somebody
and there was a woman you remember this
woman she was sitting there and she
looked at me
like
oh my God you know uh people that aren't
familiar with Firearms like they look at
a gun like it's just oh yeah they're
totally petrified of it yeah she looked
at me like I was that gun like it was
and and I realized like that's a crazy
thing to say to say listen we're about
to teach you something in the next two
and a half minutes we're gonna teach you
how to murder somebody how to kill
somebody that's what you're gonna learn
because that's and it just happened in
New York you saw that Subway Case uh the
the the former Marine put a rear naked
choke on the dude I don't know enough
details about it to know what went down
because I heard different stories so far
but
you put a rear naked joke on somebody
for an extended period of time they're
gonna die that's what's gonna happen
yeah people
people kind of realize like what how
much power that is when you have that
power and then you've also got to
realize
look that person has a knife you know
you put them in a rear naked choke they
pull out that knife and stick you six
times in the in the thigh and now you
got a femoral bleed and you die in a
minute and a half yeah what's it worth
yeah and there's a time and place and I
think the impact is like you could be uh
the alpha or Apex but you there's a time
and place like if I have my kids with me
which the majority of time I do there is
nothing more important and sacred than
those children's security and safety and
so I'm weighing that I don't need to get
in the confrontation and most of those
conversations revolve around ego and
again the idea here is we're surviving
and thriving in these environments we're
not on the back end of reacting because
you know we want to win the argument or
the debate it's not worth it it's not
worth it the ego probably has the
biggest kill count in a in America oh
yeah 100 like hey what did you mean we
just answered a question like this I
want to run on the podcast the guy's
like hey you know what what are you
doing someone just caught you in line
and you just you know you struck around
and we're kind of like brown like man
like someone cuts you lied to the
grocery store you're gonna he said
Terror like I want to rip their rotator
cuff apart and they're like bro like
because someone cut you with mine man
you know how many problems when someone
cuts you in line and is it is an
do you have any issues they have in
their life
you know they push you away like you
hear me issues that human being has no
like they got all kinds of freaking
issues they don't have any friends their
wife hates them their kids hate them
their job is terrible like they they got
issues man you don't need to add to
their issues you should just be like
yeah go ahead man no problem that's
that's how you win in that situation you
win by de-escalating the conflict before
it even starts put your freaking ego in
check like who who are you how can you
be so insecure that you like I'm gonna
kill this guy that's the first world
perspective oh damn uh
let's see yeah CCW Echo now we're
talking about the CCW classes when you
go to those in California the CCW
classes is basically
like what was the quote that you used
well you used it to me to use back to
you okay it's one big class on why not
to shoot somebody no but then you said
when you pull the trigger you probably
heard this one too well uh to think
about it in terms of if you pull the
trigger just uh assume that your name
address social security number and bank
account is written on the book
it's true it is a it's true class in
what's going to happen if you shoot
somebody yeah and it doesn't matter like
you you paint the worst case scenario
that you can possibly think of and
you're still like going to jail you're
going to spend some amount of time in
jail you're gonna spend a huge amount of
money legally like it's just
stuff that you really need to think
through now does that mean you shouldn't
be prepared no you absolutely should be
prepared because obviously
um
there's times when you got to do it yeah
there's going to be consequences to
every action and the guy in Dallas Texas
who winded up killing that protester I
mean dude so dude's a military guy
part-time ubering and drops off a
protester out of protest he's in the
middle of it this guy walks up with an
AK-47 and AK-47 in the middle of a
protest he he thinks his life's in
danger that's his perspective it's a
stand your ground state by the way which
that would extend in castle doctrine
with the both castle doctrine and
standard ground in Texas it would extend
to the domicile of his vehicle which was
and that guy he felt like he raised the
gun that's his perspective he felt like
his life was in danger he winds up
killing this guy and now he's spending
the rest of his life in prison I mean he
just got charged and he just got
sentenced to 25 years I believe and now
he's in prison the the governor of Texas
governor Abbott is saying that he will
pardon him but that's what we're banking
on here like when even when you have all
the law to back you what it depends on
is the district attorney the political
agendas of that attorney and then how
they paint the picture because that
picture if you if I say it out loud on
this podcast and people are like
clear-cut case of self-defense well how
it was painted to that jury it was a
clear-cut case of murder so always
remember like you know even like one of
the things that's always kind of
disturbed me is this retracted gun in
civilian training where you you're
you're practicing shooting retracted and
and no offense to the guys who teach it
because I think it's a valuable tool you
should understand that skill set in
close proximity fights except the people
who teach it including myself who come
from a military background we had the
Rules of Engagement to back us you grab
my gun in combat and if you're enemy
combatant I'm killing you right you you
uh get in a conflict physically with me
I'm going to kill you this is not combat
right so I've had a student before who
said he went through that training where
you retract the pistol you offset it and
you break shots and I said to him
because this is a good question because
the the whole scenario in this retracted
gun you're in physical contact with a
person so I said what is the situation
in which you attract a gun and shoot a
person and their abdomen you'd likely
start in their abdomen and Stitch them
all the way up through what was the
situation well I don't know in a bar
like what explain to me bar well I don't
know if a guy like got in a fight with
me like a head-butted me okay so if a
guy head-butted you which means he
physically assaulted you and you pulled
a pistol retracted and you shot and
killed that person you would spend the
rest of your life in prison and and the
most conservative city and state in
America is like what do you mean I think
well number one and can still carry you
can't have a gun or firearm and
concealed or overtly carried in a place
where they serve alcohol that's that's
one because that's like the precursor to
them saying he was already illegally
caring and then he was physically
assaulted did that warrant and justify
self-defense and using deadly force
because you just killed this guy like oh
so when it would be a good situation I'm
like likely there's not many scenarios
that I can come with come up with maybe
if the guy headbutted you and then drew
a knife to stab you in the chest and you
grabbed his wrist and you and you press
checked or you retracted the gun and
shot him maybe then but you have to
understand all the Technical Training
that you're learning which is you
introducing these tactics to a scenario
you have to understand the scenario in
its complexity you can't just get a tour
of tactics an immediate react
immediately react and go oh reference
tools 6 slash B retracted gun because
there would be an inappropriate response
in a retracted gun in close proximity
especially an assault likely there are
not juries who are going to say oh he
got punched in the face and then the
dude shot him oh that guy's going to
jail for murder because that's how works
it's like oh maybe we should have this
conversation maybe we should talk about
these things in decision making yeah the
uh the one in Texas that you're talking
about the AK-47
that that uh you hear people or I've
heard people talking about LARPing do
you know what LARPing yes yeah live
action role-playing which is normally
like people medieval times people that
are doing Renaissance Fairs and stuff
and they're doing nothing but lightning
bolt right and you like get into chuckle
cool good for them
um I don't want to go too hard on
LARPing because Jason Gardner might be
might be listening and you never know
dude Jason Carter might be LARPing right
now doing some swinging the swords yeah
he's saying a swinging a sword right now
playing some d d all good that's my
brother right there
but the point in that story or the
reason I brought that up is because
[Music]
you know okay this guy's gonna spend the
rest of his life in jail
the other guy's dead the guy that was
dead the guy that's dead I can just
about guarantee you
he in his mind was out thinking he's the
ruler of you know like no one's gonna
mess with him he's got an ak-47.
and you just don't know what you're
doing you don't know who you're up
against you don't know that you got a
guy that's a veteran that's that's been
under threat before and you don't raise
an AK-47 another person and expect not
to die there it's a naive LARPing person
it's a live-action role-playing person
that takes an AK-47
begins to aim it at another human being
and doesn't expect to die like that's
just a naive idiot person that is doing
uh that is making the biggest and the
last mistake that they're going to make
in their life
so there's that the other thing about
this is you know this is something they
hit on Big Time in the concealed carry
courses
like you pull out your gun
now any cop that sees you
I mean you arrive on the scene there's
somebody shooting somebody you're
getting shot so you better figure out
you better really really know what the
hell you're doing and uh think through
it and then train for it
and then train for you know you get Leah
who dumps three rounds into a guy and
she's standing there Frozen and a cop
comes around the corner and sees her
with her weapon aimed at someone else
who's now on the ground what was that
cop might shoot her yeah that's happened
too so these are the things that you
really truly have to mentally think
through and then you have to physically
train through because as Leah said
there's a huge gap between hey I talked
through this I understood what my own
personal Rules of Engagement were I
understood my ethical and moral I knew
what my trigger points were and then
when it happens it's like a totally
different thing that's why this training
that you're talking about is so freaking
important
um you got a whole section here on
everyday carry one of the most popular
hashtags on the interwebs right EDC
um and you take it you know I like the
fact that you you pointed out here
you know the reason the time you first
recognized this was you're working for
the CIA Mike don't wear those flip-flops
on base I was confused I knew the rules
I always followed the proper Army
protocol wherever I was but I'm not
working right now I said on this base
with only a handful of us here you're
always working on or off duty it clicked
immediately and stayed with me long
after I left GRS and moved into
preparedness training in the civilian
world that what you're wearing
and everything you're doing is you have
to be you're your own first responder
um and then you start talking about
going through your 80s your EDC and then
you point out it's everything from head
to toe
yeah always your own first responder a
lot of people like the first time I
realized that is I mean in the military
there's always a task and purpose it's
the right right time right place right
uniform
and what I realized in that capacity of
that job being in a country where we had
no qrf we had no support is I was my own
First Response and I couldn't lean on
any other external factors to support me
that is what a civilian has to live
through I mean you imagine you're a dad
and you're going to Disney World with
your family
everything that you do from the actions
Behavior your situation awareness all
the intangible versus the tangible
matter in a situation where you would
respond to a catastrophe because you
know we talk it from head to toe if
we're doing an operation like like say
our our joint units we're doing an
operation together and it was a low Vis
operation
we would look at the operational
environment and depending on what we try
to accomplish we would adapt the uniform
in every aspect we'd have to ditch the
sun to watches you know we had to cover
up our tattoos we have to do the mooge
beard the shemagh's whatever that
climate was we would have to adapt to it
the problem in civilian life is most
people when they think about EDC they
think about pistol
pistol is the lowest probability out of
all the things that you wear and carry
that are likely to happen I mean there's
some varying statistics on this but it's
not likely to be used I I would say
security for me and my protocol as a
principal is the number one principle
always focus on Security First as a
measure and as equipment but what else
do you have on person from your demeanor
like when we talk about demeanor we're
used to operating environments where
demeanor hits is the spike in pattern so
if you see somebody acting erratic and
their demeanor presents a certain
picture that is going to take you
through a noodle Loop that's going to
allow you to process information and
potentially act on that information in
civilian life if you want to look like a
scumbag because you just don't feel like
dressing the part you're going to dress
a certain way just know that there's a
time and place you do that and you
aren't set up properly you will
potentially get killed for it an example
would be I like to wear board shorts and
t-shirts it's not the best thing to
carry or to be functionally ready but
you can adapt that because if you have a
fanny pack this is me exercising and and
pushing fanny packs on you if you have a
sling bag for guys who don't like fanny
packs you could have that still that
same setup but also be more capable with
more capacity to carry gear and that's
what we're talking about because out of
all the things I talk about in that one
of the most important aspects where I
learned this was about
um survival
and the idea came from a survival school
that I went to the ncia and I can't talk
about too much but I went through a
survival school that basically trained
case officers to survive in
semi-permissive environments if hit
the fan so if a country falls apart and
they have to bug out the number just as
it is in reconnaissance for the military
is 72 hours so if you ask yourself right
now if something happened one do you
have ready access to that life-saving
equipment it's good to have first aid
gear but if it's in a first aid bag in
your trunk of your vehicle when you're
at inside the office when somebody was
just a casualty that's not going to help
you so you need ready access on person
so one do you have the equipment and is
it readily accessible two do you have
enough equipment on person to
potentially survive the worst case
scenario whether it be a natural or made
disaster right here right now and most
people will not and I get the whole like
um it's not convenient I mean a lot of
the equipment that we sell we think
about convenience and integrating
survival and first aid into their lives
so if right now you don't have a
tourniquet on your person okay I get it
because tourniquets are not very
comfortable to carry but do you have one
in the fanny pack okay you don't wanna
you don't have a fanny pack because you
don't want to wear one is it in your
Mobility platform is it within a
reasonable amount of time that you could
respond react and be your own first
responder that's the key with EDC
um I didn't realize until I went to the
CIA where a Glock 17 in my waistband was
my lifeline if I was lucky a partner who
had the same and if we were even lucky
or maybe a machine gun in the trunk but
we lived and worked and operated in
environments that were similar to
semi-permissive environments in America
where things are cool until they're not
and you better be able to react respond
with what you have one person and the
whole flip-flop analogy like
it's not that I'm not advocating for
flip-flops because I certainly wear
flip-flops just know what you can get
away with and know what's going to
change if you're Barefoot around gravel
and now you have to pick up your two
three-year-old Twins and shoot move and
communicate potentially save their lives
running across gravel in the middle of a
gunfight I mean sometimes you take your
losses sometimes you sacrifice it all
but try to be capable and I consciously
do this sometimes I go in a situation
I'm like
um I want to wear flip-flops but I'm
going to California I'm not taking the
risk I'm going to wear shoes and I'm
going to be able to respond that you
have to pay attention to every single
metric of that and it's not just EDC of
what you carry it's EDC of how you
present yourself John Lovell from
Warrior Poet Society has talked about
this there's several highly respected
people who who focus on this Tim Kennedy
your posture is likely to be a
mitigating factor in worst case
scenarios more than your everyday carry
pistol because if you walk around
looking weak uh deficient you're likely
going to be the victim because uh bad
guys don't exploit strength they exploit
weakness so even how you carry yourself
matters and there's a time and place
I've been in operations where I've
pretended to be frail weak and broken
because that was just the demeanor but
when we're in civilian society and we're
less likely to be a victim we have to
act apart and if you have bad posture
it's like well posture is going to save
me yeah it might because you're at the
gas station pumping gas and somebody
rolls up and they pick three people who
are they going to pick the weakest of
them all and last thing on that is when
we talk about that and you look at women
the reason women are exploited most
often by Men by the way in all violent
crime
is because they're weak or they're
perceived as weak the mitigating factor
for weakness and assault sexual or not
violence
is that that one pound pistol
that is the difference between uh I
don't care if you're Leah and you're a
third degree black belt in Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu I'm 240 pounds I will Pummel your
ass to death I don't care what your
lineage is
there is a a factor there where a
woman's discrimination tool is being
able to win the fight with a tool
because that's going to mean the
difference between life and death and
especially for women so if you're a
woman listen to this and you don't carry
an everyday Care Pistol because you
think the statistics and murder is not
not viable enough for you to justify
carrying a pistol or learning about
pistol I would ask you to look at all
the violent statistic uh statistics that
are out there first and then realize you
could be a victim because if you're a
120 pound woman and you don't everyday
carry you are waiting to be a potential
victim and if you and this is statistic
based this isn't probabilities man one
of the earliest videos that we made Echo
Charles will be talking about
self-defense I was like oh yeah that
someone asked what's the best form of
self-defense I was like best performance
self-defense is a pistol that's what you
should do you if you really are if
you're because I start I'm thinking to
myself like if I'm talking to a legit
whoever asked this Ram random question
on the internet if it's a 120 pound
woman that lives in some bad area and
she's saying hey what's the best form of
self-defense and I say it's Jiu Jitsu or
it's Muay Thai or whatever that's just
not true and
you if you really are in a situation
where you need to protect yourself and
you're 120 pounds you need to get a
pistol
when I do talk to females especially
about training about training martial
arts specifically about training jitsu
and they can come back to me then with
like well if you're saying I'm 120
pounds and you're saying that a 240
pound guy can still even if I know Jiu
Jitsu can still subdue me and control me
what's the point in even doing this
the answer to that is also very simple
when you know how to defend yourself you
might buy yourself an extra six seconds
you might buy yourself an extra eight
seconds you might present yourself with
a posture that someone
says oh I'm not going to mess with this
woman but even if it's four extra
seconds where somebody sees the license
plate of a vehicle that you're getting
stuffed into or a cop Drives By in those
10 seconds or another bystander comes by
like those seconds can absolutely save
your life and if you know how to fight
you'll be able to make that like you try
you try grabbing Leah you you try
grabbing Leah and try and see you think
you're gonna get her into a freaking
vehicle like I'm a black belt too it's
going to take me some time and effort
like it's going to be hard it's going to
be it's gonna be a fight and so learn
that stuff and
even if you are armed and someone grabs
you don't expect it and you know Jiu
Jitsu you're going to be able to be
comfortable being grabbed you're going
to be used to that and it's going to be
very beneficial to you flip-flops if
you're one of these people that thinks
well if I get into a bad situation I'll
just suck it up and I'll be able to run
across that gravel and it's no big deal
this is another like assessment that you
need to do yourself it's you
you get into unless you have Indian feet
you know which if you grow up and you're
on the beach all the time and you're
wearing you're never wearing shoes you
can you can I know my freaking Sons like
that like that dude could just run I've
seen him run across legit gravel no
Factor because he grew up not wearing
shoes but a normal person you're not
going to be able to do that I can't do
that I can't do that if I'm gonna be
more than 50 to 100 yards away from my
territory
I can't wear flip-flops you have to be
in a situation where you go okay like
anytime you're going somewhere
um
whatever you're going out for dinner in
downtown and you're gonna valet your car
you're in a situation you cannot wear
flip-flops not allowed if you're in a
situation where you're gonna go and
you're gonna go to the gym and you're
gonna park in the parking lot and you
got 30 meters into the parking lot or 30
meters back to your car
I'll cut you a little leeway
don't let it get outside that bubble
though I'm a flip-flop guy you know if
I'm not Barefoot I'm wearing flip-flops
but don't lie to yourself and don't
press the envelope or push the envelope
on those because
if you get caught you're not going to be
able to suck it up and run across gravel
or or or broken glass or whatever you're
not going to be able to do it
so be careful of that one
um what else do you cover in this
pistols you cover you cover pistols you
cover knives talking about tactical
knives versus survival knives Hybrid
models dude get this book it's good
information non-lethal
you talk about stun guns and sprays and
you give some very pertinent information
on those two things you those are things
you need to think through
those are things you need to think
through you need to read the book and
then you need to assess where you're at
as a human
um because they're different
like a stun gun cool and what's nice
about stun guns is they're legal like
you can go huh I don't want to quote I
don't know I'm getting myself an illegal
says yeah but you they're they're almost
everywhere you can carry like a stun gun
almost everywhere so if you're not
comfortable with Firearms or your the
Firearms aren't allowed in a place that
you're going and you're not a person
that has the ability to carry everywhere
then maybe you need to look into those
options same thing with pepper spray
um bear spray pepper spray all those
things you do a great job covering this
stuff
and then you get into this survival
thing
um
when I train survival in the context of
everyday carry like you said the
framework for that training is 72 hours
you want to be able to survive for 72
hours you go through what you need for
medical what you need for shelter and
Fire
you what you need for food and water
like what does that get you for 72 hours
like like me I don't carry food for 72
hours not doing it I would barely carry
food on a 72-hour operation like I'm not
carrying food I'm
got PL I'm a well-marbled individual I
can go I can go some distance yeah I'm
some straight up wagyu I can it doesn't
bother me I can go in the field and and
I used to bring like one MRE main meal a
day that's it and that takes up no space
and it's no weight but if you're a
person because I know people that need
food they start freaking out without
food
but water
bro I'm loading it out same do you sweat
a lot oh bro yeah yeah
you cut some veins in here you're
getting butter and crisco and water and
that's most Americans too yeah
um you talk about illumination you know
what what do you mean by illumination
we're talking about freaking flashlights
the difference between having a
flashlight and not having a flashlight
like blind or not big it's blind or not
being blind it's it's totally insane and
to not have a flashlight in your vehicle
this is totally insane not having a
flashlight in in your first line or
second line kit you're gonna have issues
with that
so
think about these things signaling
devices you go through your whole
everyday carry
um including bags thinking what you guys
sell a bunch of everyday carry stuff
what you carry what do you sell a butt
pack pretty much everything like the
fanny pack the the first aid equipment
some survival components
um I think the most important aspect if
I was going to talk about two things
would be the tourniquet and the bleeding
control kit because they're very man
packable I mean they're they're
something that you can stuff in your
pocket if you wanted to opt that way
um but the in my opinion the most
important elements of of everyday carry
that aren't focused on that need to be
is putting first aid first you know
including a tourniquet yeah that
tourniquet man that's why I started with
that story what would have travesty
I have to read this part even though you
kind of covered a little bit I want to
at least mention one thing you said if
there's one thing I've learned over 20
years in the military intelligence
service in war zones and hostile
territory it's how they carry yourself
is truly your first line of defense when
you stand tall when you stay alert when
you are aware of everything around you
when you look like you know what you're
doing and how to handle yourself violent
threats tend to find you less often and
we actually did a podcast about
they interviewed a bunch of criminals
violent criminals and the the common
thread of people that they looked to
avoid that criminals didn't want to
attack the term that that bubbled to the
surface was people that looked organized
really yep people look organized people
uh victimizers are they think that that
looks like Trump interesting yeah it's
an interesting what are characteristics
of organizations
here I think it's looking squared away I
think it's a head on a swivel it's like
oh this person has purpose in life
they're they're aware of what's
Happening
um then you say this not only that but
when you carry yourself that way you
will begin to feel that way and then
you'll start to act that way it's just
the way the mind works if you want to be
less sad smile more the smile comes
before the happiness there's an old
saying fake it till you make it it's
true project confidence and confidence
display capacity and capability even if
you're not totally there yet and soon
enough you will feel like you you will
feel and be all those things and being
all those things will make you make
projecting them effortless and
unconscious it becomes a flywheel of
sorts that spins off many positive
things including most importantly
preparedness
my only comment on that is just be
careful
because you start Faking It Faking It
and you can be made you'll get made yeah
you want to fake it but you want to
definitely make sure you're freaking
know what you're doing and don't don't
become don't go back into the ignorance
and arrogance category yeah which can
happen real quickly like with flip-flops
I can just suck it up bro
my my freaking son we were up at
Yosemite he did like one of those like
hikes like a big hike where people are
wearing you know uh they're carrying the
poles and they're wearing freaking Sorel
boots in the whole nine yards he's
Barefoot bro just like what is this
freaking deal that's awesome uh
next section you start getting into
mobility and what does that mean in a
worst case scenario one of the surest
tactics to avoid becoming a casualty is
having a well-rehearsed plan of Escape
Invasion and a well-equipped vehicle in
other words loading up your car truck or
motorcycle to get off the X and you had
a whole chapter we didn't cover it about
getting off the X what that means why
it's important
um and increase the the probability of
your survival and then you get into
vehicle selection you know what you can
use a vehicle for a vehicle is shelter
right
um
what is your thing I owe you in on or
under
I gotta I've got an addendum to you so
you can rooftop camping you can go under
I've got a note three times in here you
know what it says it says ground pack
ground pack ground pad because you talk
about my large blanket you talk about
sleeping bags but it doesn't say ground
pad it needs a great you need a ground
beef dude that will save your life to me
I thought to myself you know what ground
pad is so embedded in Mike's brain that
he didn't put it in here it is yeah it's
always been attached to my rug somewhere
you have to have a ground Pat 100 you
have to have a ground pad I'll take a
ground pad over sleeping bag all day
long ground pad is like you need a
freaking ground pad I did I was going
through calm school or going on an FTX
and I was a new guy I didn't even have
my Trident yet but I was at a team and
they sent me right to calm School
on the East Coast it was our great calm
School run by this freaking crazy calm
Chief um seal and we did a seven day FTX
and he tells me like a willink if you're
really hard you'll go in there with just
a poncho and a poncho liner and I'm like
check watch this
so we go in I'm just I literally have a
poncho and a poncho liner my Poncho did
have a zip on it you know like you put
zippers on it to make it kind of a
sleeping bag
but um
no ground pad no barrier between the
earth we as we inserted it it was
raining oh and then it turned to sleep
oh no it turned to snow no and you had
to make calms like every two to four
hours and most guys would you win
two-man pairs I was with GIF by the way
yeah we you had to make comms every two
to four hours and most guys would like
Miss calm Windows because they would
fall asleep you know because it's 24
hours a day yeah and we never missed a
calm window why because we weren't
sleeping because we were freezing
so ground Pat get yourself a ground pack
unless you want to pass Cowboy school
don't bring it down
um
yeah you get through just all the stuff
with with mobility and again all the way
down to Communications and what you're
gonna do what's your plan your first aid
what does that look like inside your
vehicle those are all just critical
things that you need to think about
you get into motorcycles like you you do
the whole nine yards man
um and then the last section here is
about your house your homestead we began
this book and this preparedness journey
by talking about the importance and
Primacy of mental resilience in survival
we're going to end it by talking about
the importance of creating physical
resilience within your homestead
outfitting your homestead is critical to
get right it's where you live it's where
you raise your kid it's your shelter
it's your security it's where your
survival is sustained and where your
preparation could be the difference
between thriving and just getting by or
not
and this is like kind of your expertise
Beyond expertise is setting up security
right yeah as a weapons guy
um
and these are
you know you you point this on it I
didn't really highlight any of this just
because I don't I just don't care about
it I but I understand you had to address
it you talk about a few times in the
book like listen
this isn't crazy you're not you're not
crazy because you think through the
security of your house this doesn't make
you a paranoid prepper that's nuts
that's wearing a tinfoil hat it doesn't
do that
and you address it in the book you know
not not huge but you at least mentioned
it
but if you don't look at your house and
think to yourself like oh
how vulnerable is my family
how vulnerable is my family to a break a
b and e how vulnerable is my family to a
fire how vulnerable is my family to
where are the electrical wires that are
around my house
what kind of security do I have
what other like the neighbor's dog what
kind of dog does the neighbor have what
kind of dog like all these basic things
you're not paranoid
and you're not a crazy person to Think
Through The Safety and Security of your
family in their house this is not
matter of fact not only are you not
crazy if you do it as far as I'm
concerned you're crazy if you don't do
it
but go watch the news for a half an hour
and then decide you don't want to just
do a little sanity check on your
residence to make sure that it makes
sense how it's set up
this is common sense stuff that's not
happening
and and you know you mentioned earlier
like um the guilt someone would have
can you imagine if something happens in
your house
and and something happens to one of your
family members because you didn't take a
half an hour to sit down and talk with
your wife about what you're going to do
if there's a fire in our house
how are the kids going to get out of the
Second Story window well they're going
to come down the hallway what if the
hallways where the fire is
shoulder shrug is that what we're doing
so do you guys offer a course where you
start talking about
assessing your house yeah for sure the
first course we actually call this level
three of basic pistol defense and also
uh carbine defense but the idea in one
through three is learning the basics is
one obviously with two we take those
Basics and we introduce them in new
environments and then you're doing
pistol defense in and around vehicles in
level two and level three we're focusing
on the home and a lot of the things that
are built around the home are built off
the idea that with Mobility just like
from everyday carry to Mobility from
Mobility to your home your increasing
capacity so if I have a tourniquet on my
person I want a first aid bag in my
vehicle I want a stretcher and
antibiotics in my home right I have this
space so I'm reinforcing and building
everything out with home security we
offer a personal security course because
cqd which is closer defense is very
different than Close Quarters battle it
is not offensive it is very defensive
there is surreptitious movement involved
and you know the layout of your home so
it's not like I need to seek points of
domination and clear it and I'm also by
myself you know CQB is a collective task
cqd is a very individual task and the
consideration and tactics are very
different so it's important to delineate
the difference and I I look at Homestead
as one of the most important elements of
preparedness but it's also the funnest
component of preparedness I have go look
I've never I grew up in Daytona Beach
Florida
I grew up in North Carolina in the
boonies and when I went in the military
I spent the rest of my time overseas I
had never grew up with I mean I grew up
messing around in chicken and pig farms
and stuff like that but I never raised
chickens and did all this stuff I've I
have chickens like my chickens just
dumped 30 eggs on us yesterday my kids
eat like a dozen eggs every morning but
I have eggs or I have how many chickens
do you have I have ten okay yeah that's
a lot of eggs so I get crushing eggs so
I have uh 10 chickens Ducks goats I just
slaughtered a wagyu steer with 600 plus
pounds of meat fed my company with a
whole bunch of meat
um I'm doing a greenhouse gardening
outside bees
um renewable energy sources I'm doing it
all and the reason I think it's
important is because it is bringing my
family closer together but I'm also
learning through all these mechanisms of
cutting the umbilical cord to the
institution we have so much Outsource in
our lives there are little things in
your life that you could take back and
it will benefit both your level of
preparedness but so your relationship
with your family I think homestead's one
of the most important things I should
mention that Homestead includes things
like family preparedness uh Miss Amber L
who works for me teaches family
preparedness for a company
she teaches canning and jarring she
teaches homeschooling your kids all
these things are things that matter
they're all segments but they're all I
think equally as important as all the
things that we look at
you rattle off that list of stuff and
I'm sitting over here thinking like
again going back to my example it
doesn't really cost you anything to walk
into a room and be like okay there's the
exits okay there's some good cover over
there think of what's the downside of
having bees of having chickens of having
goats like what's the downside oh your
kids understand nature you get to spend
time with them your food is like from
The Source it's nothing but upside
nothing but upside
like these are just totally positive
things to execute on
yes and the the important element which
are trying to shape and change culture
is this is not a hobby
the idea of a hobby is its very
part-time it's something that spikes
your dopamine you get excited and then
you go back to mundane life
the key here is saying just like the
special operator that we talked about in
the beginning who is putting himself In
Harm's Way on purpose deliberately but
coming out on top is because his entire
lifestyle
is immersed in culture this is a culture
and I think the last component to this
book that we talk about is community
because all of these things that we talk
about bring together what I think is the
most or the less divisive thing in our
life that we could agree upon because if
you're a republican you're a liberal
you're somewhere in between if you came
to a seminar in photograph survival you
have something in common you care about
bringing yourself and your community
together over preparedness you want to
protect your family and when you bring
both uh sides of the aisle together it's
a beautiful thing and I've seen it
happen across the country where people
like I'm kind of interested in this and
there's guys from California there's
guys from Montana and they're like on
different sides of the spectrum and
they're going maybe I should pay
attention to this that relationship and
networking and building Community is the
most important element of of all which
is without a community
um without a looking my neighbors as
assets and liabilities without building
my network
you're not going to survive the whole
idea of Lone Survivor the whole idea of
the Lone Wolf mentality will not will
not execute well
at Echelon we talk about something
called the ladder of alignment which
means you know you and I have a business
together and you want to do something
one way and I want to do something the
other way and we're start arguing about
it we can't come to a resolution
because you you think we should invest
the money in marketing and I think we
should invest the money in product and
so we're arguing
and what we do is we climb the ladder of
alignment and we we go okay well what
what do we both want do we both want the
company to be profitable yes we do do we
both want to take care of our team yes
we do we do do we both want to take care
of our clients yes we do okay so
let's figure out how we work together
based on the fact that we all we want
the same thing and what you just
mentioned you're someone from Montana
and someone from California
even those people some crazy freaking
blue-haired liberal from California and
some you know
Rancher from Montana
they can both say well do you both want
to take care of your families do you
both want to be able to protect your
families do you both want to be
self-sufficient do you both want to know
where your food comes from do you both
want to be able to handle yourself under
stressful situations like it's yes yes
yes yes yes across the board so maybe
everybody you're a little less different
than you think you are
um
and that's what you're saying here it's
your community that's going to protect
you it's your neighbors who are going to
help you out it's your local Merchants
Farmers mechanics doctors and nurses who
are going to make sure you and your
family don't starve or freeze or suffer
die when you find yourself in a bad spot
we forget that sometimes we lose sight
of the fact it's not what you know it's
who you know
I mean that's something we throw around
all the time
um
and
it's real you you talk you mentioned
here American contingency tell us about
American contingency American
contingency.com this is what you got in
trouble for I heard you talking to Rogan
about this right you got you got label
the terrorists yeah so I I don't think I
got I think I got uh put in a box where
everybody assumed that
um I was looked at as a domestic
terrorist and I think part of that is
true but most certainly American
contingency got looked at as a militia
violent extremist organization mve is
the new coin term I've had guys in the
FBI both confirm that project Veritas
linked the information and the documents
that prove that and what it was was they
identified that American contingency
could be a a nest or a hotbed for
potential
um extremists that wanted to build their
networks except that were not extremists
we moderate all of our content we look
at everybody who's on board we have a
vetting process where we want people to
build communities again like we used to
do like when I grew up I knew my
neighbors I mean I remember growing up
and being in people's houses I had no
idea but my dad knew who they were and
they were making phone calls because we
didn't have cell phones at the time like
where the hell is the sun the calling
landlines like three houses down oh he's
on the third house after the third phone
call so that is a Miss in our country I
mean we we live next to people where we
go you know we scowl at our neighbor
because we try to run in from our
vehicle to our door so we don't get seen
by our neighbor I guess we'd rather you
know interact with people on social
media we also live in apartment
complexes were stacked on top of each
other and you know nobody around you the
problem with that is throughout history
every single study done on catastrophe
has proven that the link in in
connection with people has meant the
difference between surviving and
thriving or potentially losing it all
and so uh American attendance sees idea
a concept came from the actions that
happened or the inactions really that
happened in Seattle with the mayor
basically telling the law enforcement
officers to not to do their job and I
said well that's a problem well then how
the hell are people supposed to Resource
and connect well Facebook is like
canceling people offline because they're
conservatives or because whatever we
need to start a group and so that was
the launch of American contingency to
use as a form and mechanism for people
to connect and we have groups all over
the country like I just met with a group
at Greg Anderson's place a buddy of mine
in pnw and pnw was like I mean the
hotbed for all this drama that was
unfolding but a group came out to see me
because I go around the country teaching
and it was a group of doctors lawyers
mechanics and they basically built their
own operational Detachment of capability
and assets working with each other they
have family barbecues they go out to the
range together they do teachable c the
doctors are teaching first aid and
Trauma
um there's Financial people who are
given Financial advice and people are
like the government would look at that
and go that's a militia I would look at
that and go that's resilient Americans
and so
um if the Red Dawn ever does happen we
want a capable
um group of communities Across the
Nation that are capable of taking care
of themselves if it doesn't come what
we're building is resilience in America
where people can depend on each other
and that's the key here I mean all the
things I mean it's funny because we did
this for a living by with and through
for me I don't want to be the commander
of American contingency I started it and
it runs itself Tom and the and the team
at American contendency run this these
groups are organically building
themselves up and we are just giving
them the tools and the template for how
to do it properly and ethically and what
we're seeing is a profound group of
Americans coming together and that's
what American contingency is about it's
like a Facebook group that you belong to
isn't your network and your asset and
your family or your friends you actually
have to get out and meet these people in
real life shake their hands and go hey
let's build relationships that's what
American continency is all about and
that's an American contingencies that
American contingency yep American
contingency.com yep
right on hey I want to close out with
this section of the book
um
you say this in the 21st century we've
had a major terrorist attack two Wars
more than 300 school shootings riots
political unrest massive hurricanes
forest fires tornadoes floods Bridge
collapses supply chain collapses
recessions and a pandemic
and that's mostly just the United States
I'm talking about I don't say any of
this to scare you the purpose of this
note and this book is not to frighten
you it's not to highlight your
deficiencies or to tell you what to do
the reason I wrote this book is to give
you the mental and physical tools you
need to live a prepared life to thrive
in that life to know that you have what
it takes both literally and figuratively
to protect yourself defend your family
and support your community in the event
of catastrophe to know that you can know
that you will survive the worst day of
your life my one wish for you as you
reach the End of This Book Is that in
Supply in applying its advice insights
tools methods tactics and strategies to
your life you are inspired to do
everything in your power to become more
self-reliant and to spend more of your
precious time with your family and
friends than on your phone
I want more than anything for you to be
able to rest easy after A Hard Day's
Work To Love well and live free not just
for yourself
but for your future for the future of
your children and your children's
children trust me they will thank you
for it and we will all be better off not
just as individuals but as a community
and as a nation if first and foremost we
are prepared for anything
Come What May
um
yeah there you go uh
life is good
until it goes bad and
don't wait for it to go bad don't wait
for it and by the way there's just no
downside there's just no downside
there's no downside to training there's
no downside to hanging out with your
family there's no downside to discussing
what to do and
stressful situations with your kids
there's no downside to it there's none
there's all upside and if nothing ever
happens great but if it does happen
you're ready
I think um
this book is is what I think this book
is
there's obviously a ton of good good
information I probably read five percent
of the book today maybe if that the rest
of it I didn't cover a lot of the
detailed information that you've given
there there's a ton of it in there and
it's a starting point you know it's a
starting point it's a starting point to
open up your eyes open up your mind and
realize how much more you can do as an
individual human being to help yourself
and help your family and help everyone
around you
it's gonna be powerful man
I appreciate it when does it come out
man June 6 D-Day June 6th D-Day it's
right on
um
what else what let's talk about where
can people find you get engaged right
now what do we got we got field
fieldcraft survival.com yeah
philcastsurvival.com is is is the main
website there will be
um an application for virtual education
all things from canning and jarring to
self-defense to Mobility all the things
that we talk about in the book that will
be released that same day on all eight
major channels it's like Roku Samsung
Apple TV all the things because we want
you to have the ability to interact but
also watch this on the big screen at
home uh not just on your phone or your
tablet that will be releasing the same
day uh if people are interested in
everything that we're doing most of the
things that we offer cost absolutely
nothing that's Phil grass survival as a
YouTube channel Mike Glover actual has a
YouTube channel and then our podcast
digests as much as that as possible and
if you think it's something that you're
interested in go to the website attend
training do the online application
do all the things my goal and objective
is
I want a Phil Craft Survival Firebase or
Outpost firebase's company owned Outpost
is like a hybrid version of it in every
major city and every state in this
country I want the preparedness YMCA of
the future the modern version of that to
be accessible to not only prepare people
for the worst case scenario but to build
culture and Community back into the
fabric of our nation that's my ultimate
goal with Phil crossover
and they have you have field Craft
Survival
on Instagram fieldcraft Survival on
Facebook fieldcraft Survival on YouTube
and Twitter it's on all those things and
then you are you Mike A Glover on
Instagram yeah it's mike.a.glover on
Instagram and my backup is my clever
actual because most of the stuff that I
do on my.a.gover it gets suppressed like
everything else
uh and then also we already mentioned
American contingency.com
That's it man I appreciate it Echo
Charles yes sir you ready you ready for
the questions did you hear when he asked
Admiral uh Admiral mcraven if he had to
be in the Navy if you have to be in the
Navy to be an admiral
that's after his after Admiral Craven's
second time on the podcast and after
after Echo Charles beating this podcast
for 300 and something episodes talking
military history talking to Veterans we
gotta say Echo you got any questions and
echo says Hey Admiral uh do you need to
be in the Navy to be an animal no that's
the slight Miss representation of the
question so thank you though it was how
do I become Admiral
[Music]
I'll have to review the tapes he kind of
looked at me for a second like hold on a
second dude are you serious right now
and I just looked at him like bro I
wasn't sure if he was serious or not
because let's face it that's an ignorant
freaking question right there so I look
at mcraven like you know I I'm pretty
sure he's serious that he just said well
yes yes in order to be in the Navy in
order to be an animal you do have to be
able to give a very uh graceful gracious
answer for sure but again he was talking
to a four-year-old
see that part is true yes but no it was
how does one become Admiral like that
like the process like the actual you
know process that was a legitimate
question that's what I was asking
there was like a little party in it that
I threw in I was like wait so I gotta be
in the Navy or whatever like it was like
that you are rewriting history
all right hey believe what you want but
that's the way it went down you know hey
we got the props to Echo he left it in
there he had the chance he could have
edit it out made himself look a little
bit smarter you think I'm the only one
that ever wondered that in the history
of I don't know podcasts and Admirals
right you're crazy because that's a
legitimate question in my opinion bro
I know it's actually not no one's
wondering that all right well okay well
that being said here's the hard-hitting
question here we go here we go all right
I'm ready I'm ready okay
so uh okay actually it's actually a
small question so you know how like um
you know the EDC kind of thing you know
how you see the um on YouTube like the
pocket dump right yeah
do you do or do you like um like collect
things you know some people like knives
so they have a bunch of like knives that
they kind of I guess compulsively
collect or whatever I have drawers fully
DC everything oh everything well I'll
see you okay I have I just went through
this I have drawers of flashlights
because we test and assess different
lights we we go through lights
um knives
wallets RFID wallets holsters and I
would probably put guns in that category
as well so do you are they for like
because that kind of sounds functional
like hey I got a test I got to see if
this one works better for me or whatever
but is there anything specific or type
of thing where you go on Amazon and you
know Amazon they they got an algorithm
like everything else yeah you buy one
knife may or may not be speaking of from
experience where you buy one and then
they show you the other cool one you
know and you're like oh let me this you
know like is there anything like that do
you do justification for five more
knives here's the thing he's buying like
you know those crazy fantasy knives oh
yeah yeah that's what he buys yeah
[Music]
so what's legitimate about this and we
teach people this in EDC most people
default to EDC as being one end-all
be-all solution so they say Mike what's
your EDC pistol and I said what time of
day is it what what's the weather what
state am I in right how am I feeling I
mean sometimes I carry hkp7 which is
activated based off you gripping the
module which is a a safety mechanism and
gripping down on the gun and it's a nine
mil and it's not very practical as an
EDC carry except I have kids right so if
my three and a half year old suddenly
finds my discovers my pistol because I I
neglected to keep it on person and they
picked that gun up he doesn't have the
dexterity and and size of hand to
actually grip down on that and break
break a shot Glock 19 in the waistband
single action only there's no options
there right One in the Chamber it's just
gonna happen so what I would say is
every single facet of EDC there's a time
and place and there's an operational
environment where those things apply
like same thing with the knives hey what
knife do you carry zdc I'm like most of
the time I carry a folding blade for
utility but it it's Dual Purpose is
self-defense some guys carry fixed
blades for self-defense as a priority
over utility I'm mostly cutting open
boxes with a knife so I focus on utility
just like I displace a flashlight
because I don't like lights Tethered to
guns most of the time because most guns
that I use don't have very comfortable
holsters to carry so I have options for
all of the things in EDC and I would say
the more options the better it's like
wearing clothes have plenty of options
and be able to work those options into
your EDC for the um for the event right
different attire for different different
attire for different events so that's
like the and that actually is very
useful because I think a lot of I know
I'm one of these people who don't really
think about that part of it you know
they're like hey I'm gonna get that
knife because it's like it kind of looks
cool it flips up sounds good very
comfortable you know but it you know
depends on where you are and what kind
of circumstance very responsible but I'm
talking about the slightly less
responsible part of my Glover that's
like a Desert Eagle 50 cal have you
completed hey man there's a time in
place is nickel plated stainless oh
there you go stainless okay
this is legit yeah solid yeah um but no
the kind of like compulsively collect
like hey you know you know what I'm
talking about like some guys will do
that with guns they'll be like hey that
new
19x came out or whatever I do that with
guns I do it backwards though like I I
what's weird is if you're if you live by
the gun which my profession Jaco's
profession live by the gun guns don't do
it for me but you know what do it for me
like you give me a lever action or a A
Single Action Army cowboy gun from 1860s
old school dude I I have more of those
guns than I have modern guns okay so I'm
that guy yeah I have tons of cowboy guns
yeah western guns I have flashlights I
don't know why flashlights you're into
illumination man yeah man illumination
oh yeah we gotta asked one time about a
home defense weapon and one of the
weapons I recommended I don't know where
I don't know where the person was
writing from but um
MP5
oh it's like like think about the ease
of firing an MP5 yeah you're in your
house SD I assume it's compressed you
know and you get like frangible rounds
oh my God like you could
so good with that like your 10 year old
could just get busy with that oh yeah
and just lay it down yeah that's a good
point because that's the Tactical
Advantage most guys would use their EDC
like we differ we differentiate EDC to
Mobility to Homestead if you have your
EDC pistol and you're using that as your
home defense gun you're wrong if you
have your uh EDC pistol and you're using
it as your truck gun or your vehicle gun
you're wrong because if you look at the
ballistics the terminal ballistics of a
nine mil pistol from inside the car
shooting out not very good on glass or
or metal but if you look at 300 blackout
in a a a pistol version of an AR pistol
version of it shooting Through a
Windshield no deviation and hold no
Factor so those things are important to
look at and there's always a tactical
Advantage like my Homestead Home Defense
Weapon It's a Sig 320 x Legion because I
like the tungsten weight in the frame
and it's it's got a suppressor and it's
got a light and people are like well I
thought you didn't like lights I don't
like lights in EDC because I'm home
before dark because I have two
three-year-olds there that I'm bathing
and feeding before I put them read them
a bedtime a Jocko bedtime story sure
before I put them to bed so I I a home
defense gun is going to be different and
that is all the justifications for all
the guys to turn to the ladies and say
babe Mike said I got to get all the
options we got to spend some money and
invest in preparedness and then you got
to work with those weapons that you're
familiar with them all all you've got to
get the yeah the the weapons platform
you got to be familiar with it because
you don't want to do make the wrong move
with the weapon that you're not used to
you're used to shooting this one on the
range for 10 000 rounds and then all of
a sudden you didn't flip the safety on a
45 or whatever dude I I just moved I'm
moving to a staccato
um for ADC I have 15 EDC pistols I have
a 365 XL that's currently what I'm using
now but it's Single Action only my kid
my boy I have twins but my son is all
into he calls him choo choos and he
loves guns and he's like you know he's
always been around him and I kept him
unloaded on the tables on purpose so he
can get immersed in them and see them
and so he's not like oh what is that he
goes oh that's Dad's choo choo don't
touch it right and if he wants to touch
it he says Daddy can I touch it I said
yeah you could touch it you could even
hold it just point it in the right
direction it's unloaded and I'm trying
to integrate this into him well if you
take a single action pistol and pick it
up as a four-year-old with this the size
of my kids mitts now he can wrap his
hands around a clock 19 or that 365 XL
which is compact
if I have a seed I think it's called a
C2 or c c s I might be screwing this up
it's the staccato
um version of the uh everyday carry the
compact
well people are like why would you ever
go back to that I'm like I'm not going
back to it it's an option because if my
kid gets his hands on that gun he has a
thumb safety and a grip safety to get
through to break a shot and for the
first time I've actually looked at
1911's and go oh that's kind of cool but
it's kind of Novel but because I would
never use it because it's just you have
to work it I am having to retrain myself
on how to activate that thumb switch and
script down on the on the grip a certain
way because I've gotten away with using
a single ax pistol but there's a time
and place for everything and if you
don't get schooled on all these systems
you'll be deficient and I'd hate to draw
that pistol I'm going to pull that
trigger realizing I didn't even grip
down on the grip safe or I didn't drop
that thumb lever so it's all it's all
all important what'd you guys grow what
do you grow up on uh in the military the
first one was not Beretta 92F and then
we transitioned to Glock okay night
Glock 19 Glock 17.
um and then every once in a while you
find a 19 11. I was 20 straight years on
a 226. oh like it's really hard for my
muscle memory yeah and that's a
different plot a double action single
action pistol only or a single action
pistol it is very different than I mean
that the length of trigger pull is long
single action short but to get used to
that compared to a Glock 19 on the box
completely different uh with your son
and your daughter what are you doing
with toy weapons and muzzle discipline
um if if they're in a designated war
zone which is like we're going to war
they could shoot each other we could do
the whole thing and we're at War but
when we're just messing around
especially because my my gun my son
loves cowboy guns so he loves the six
shooters and he'll walk around and I've
seen him like point the gun at people
I'm like you don't do that
um you can point it at the chickens you
could point at the Ducks the goats but
you don't point it at anybody unless
we're playing and then he's like okay I
get it and and it's weird like when you
instill that and your kids at a very
young age they they correct themselves
and now my kids are correcting each
other like they say you don't I mean my
daughter is a it's a freaking Korean
woman at a heart she's like Mom she's a
tiger mom already she will literally
regulate walk in the room and like buddy
you do not Point guns at Daddy and but
he's like I'm sorry my bad
so when my son was like little maybe
like three four five six no probably
till about five maybe six I was like
muzzle discipline I don't care what it
was yeah and then I realized how much
that sucked and how much like fun we
were not having
and I and then I changed my thing and
then it was anything like basically I
made a hardcore this uh line between
toys yeah yeah and and guns yeah and
guns was pellet guns and BB guns like
those were guns and if you then it was
like like being a team guy if you swept
like you were doing Tire pulls like
we're getting it that's what's happening
but man I had so much fun with Nerf guns
and the lasers Nerf guns like I had to
just throw that out the window and just
get crazy
I did consider that that like Nerf guns
and um and then
so I would be less uh what do you call
strict with it and then so I got him a
rubber band gun and he just assumed oh
this is cool and this way you know yeah
I'm looking this way and then you know I
see him coming doing his thing when I'm
not paying attention I look and the
rubber band goes right here he didn't
shoot me but bro what if he shoots me an
eyeball that's on me I think around my
back on honestly is not a good call
because that thing like I think a Nerf
gun is fine because even if you get
beamed in the eye with a Nerf gun you're
still it's not it's not injury because
you could probably injure somebody with
a so I look I'm not trying to sound like
a dork here but I might slide the rubber
band gun
a little bit you know what I'm saying
okay all right but you have that strict
muzzle discipline and you let them know
that like I treated a BB gun like oh
yeah I sure you treated like it was an
AR yeah you know like this is this is a
real gun you you can't you know finger
off the trigger the whole nine yards
yeah toy guns I still finger off the
trigger on the toy guns and everything
like you want them to have good muzzle
discipline but I had to just let go of
being crazy and being like yo you just
swapped your mom
dad's Nerf gun I don't care
I like yours like hey when it's go time
it's all good that's another way to do
it too yeah designated war time because
you're not gonna be like hey wartime
real guns live fire everybody you know
it's like but yeah if you have Nerf guns
it's kind of one of those things and
that's for my safety because my I mean
my son has literally stood over me and
shot me in the head with a Nerf dart and
it's like when he they don't know the
difference between play time and like
I'm sleeping it's like you need to
designate like Hey we're kick-starting
this I've also Gotten Good at like I
have locking boxes all over the house I
have one from a company called Pine
World some other company where you put
it inside of it it's like a versa I
can't remember the name of it but uh you
stick the gun into a holster and it
clicks and then to get it out you need
Biometrics so I have that at my desk
side and then the other one's a box the
pine World Box you do the Biometrics you
could do keypad or you could do key and
so the real guns are locked away loaded
but I also have loaded I have unloaded
guns all over the place so and and
people have asked me like well don't you
think that's irresponsible no because I
am demonstrating like like you want to
see your kids Behavior around guns and
the more that you make it like this this
uh secretive thing like we did and dude
I remember getting my dad's Duty gun and
literally pointing I should probably
never say this out loud but I took my
dad's Duty gun and shot out the back of
our trailer park in Florida once I think
that's the first time I've ever said
that out loud
hopefully it doesn't come back podcast
it doesn't haunt me but I literally
remember doing like getting his gun
looking in the mirror and pointing it
and it's a loaded gun it's a wait did
you have an ad out the window no no I
legitimately like opened the back and
there was a trail or a railroad yard and
there's scrap metal and everything and I
just was like I got this and it was real
loud and it scared the hell out of me
and I was like oh my God and I put it up
and I didn't even put a round back in
that gun and my dad just went around his
business I'm like I mean how much of a
it was a it was a three it was this
concealed carry gun I think it was his
ankle gun and it was a 380
semi-automatic pistol yeah that's yeah
you don't want to be how old were you
12. yeah careful yeah I'm sure you did
something there's got to be something in
the wild times oh yeah yeah the ones
that we're not talking about
uh yeah Jack
so there you go
um
Mike any uh any closing thoughts no I
just want to say thank you for the
opportunity I know uh your audience is
big into a lot of the books and
recommendations that you have brought up
um as far as I know prepared is one of
the first I mean there's plenty of
survival genre books Clint Emerson makes
some great books in worst case scenarios
um it is it is an honor and privilege to
be able to do a book
um and to be able to present it this way
so I want to say thank you for the
opportunity and um if anybody has any
questions we're in open forum for
everything preparedness related
um I also want to say Phil Craft
Survival which is my company that
teaches educates and equips people in
preparedness it's not Mike lover it is a
team of hard-working people who present
the conduit between experts and uh
people and that is important distinction
because without my team I wouldn't be
able to do anything I do so thanks to
them for getting us to this point and
thank you for the opportunity right on
man well I got the feeling that
everything's just getting warmed up at
this point and I think this book's gonna
get a lot of people engaged in what they
need to be engaging so thanks for
joining us thanks for your service again
go back to 291 if you want to hear about
some of more of Mike's story and um as a
soldier but thanks for your service
doing that and then thanks for what
you're doing today this is going to help
Americans
become better prepared and
thereby live better lives and make our
country a better place so thanks for
what you're doing bro thank you
and with that Mike Glover has left the
building
Echo Charles what kind of podcast you
like right there don't you yeah you find
it interesting you know I'm not reading
from an
1864 book about the Civil War they're
all interesting but you know sometimes
you have you know sometimes you have one
finger connection to the material
sometimes I have half a pinky connection
to the material sometimes I got all 10
fingers connected to the material how
many times did you have connected today
ten fingers actually nine because you
know I don't have military background so
we'll say nine right but the whole you
know
you know how certain content or or
certain subjects come on TV or the
internet and you can't help but kind of
watch it even though you're not heavy
into it but it's like real fun like um
you know magician stuff
um what else
practical joke sometimes another one is
is
survival stuff prep her stuff like that
kind of problem get you in the game over
there on that one plus of course you
know Mike Glover he's an awesome guy I
followed him since you know since even
before we did the first one so I'm down
I'm down for the whole gig
right on well
um for sure
being prepared like uh Mike pointed out
starts with the physical yeah the
physical fit yeah physical fitness
um so you're gonna be doing Jiu Jitsu
hey he said this working out maybe doing
getting some of that CrossFit together
both yeah well hell yeah and he
mentioned this um in the break and this
is important where he was like hey
he mentioned it a little bit in the
beginning especially he was like Hey you
have to kind of consider the probability
the likelihood of certain things you
know so when he was talking about guys
love the tactics with the guns and stuff
but hey what about you know
and he was saying uh
all-cause mortality is uh the most
probable is cardiovascular yeah oh look
at this guy with that one over there and
he started if you notice he started with
that yeah like oh cool bro but after
five minutes if you're gassing you can't
even function bro come on that's a sad
State gassing
I wonder I would like to dig into the
details a little bit more on his is it
just like do Max because you know I
could destroy myself in five minutes oh
yeah you know what I mean even if you do
burpees for one minute like if you're
going for for what do you call when you
go for the amount right best best Max
reps Max reps yeah bro
you go hard enough yeah you go hard
enough you know like sometimes at them
that's a monster it'll be a stud there
yeah and I'll go over there and start
counting their one minute's worth of
burpees like you know they're getting it
yes sir they're getting it yeah and like
even a stud will be tired but if they if
there's so we'd have to I didn't dig
into those details we'll find out what
that five minute protocol looks like
here's what I did he did say he wants
you to get your heart rate up to what he
said 120 right at 1 30. okay so either
way I think that's kind of the goal not
to see how many burpees you can do on
one of the minutes of the fight you know
like so
I don't want it but still at the same
time the point Still Remains where he's
like hey you can do all these cool shots
or whatever but bro if your body's not
even going to handle your life your
normal life and you're gonna die because
you have cardiovascular disease breasts
kind of you kind of put in the horse
ahead of the or the carriage ahead of
the horse kind of like a fight gone bad
workout oh you know that fight gone bad
workout yeah and it was like one minute
of this one minute of this one bit of
this so it's a five one minute things
one minute break and do it five times
yeah that's a good little workout for
you fight gone bad we do muster PT going
bad
it's one of the ones we do anyways hey
you're working out you're training you
got to be ready mentally physically you
got to get the right fuel in your system
go to jocofuel.com get the right fuel in
your system
get the go
rtds get the milk powder pow pow it's
got some palpo by the way yeah big time
you know
it's pretty amazing California
I was in pow pow in May yeah skiing in
the mountains is but that's not normal
right for not totally normal no right a
little bit of a Long Winter it was there
we're not complaining about them so uh
get yourself some pow pow some milk pow
pow get yourself
get yourself the The Joint Warfare yeah
you know I just
um someone just as I was walking through
the gym they just said to me the cold
war is no joke no I'm like well no it's
not uh if you feel like that little bit
of a little bit of sickness coming on
you need that immunity boost get
yourself some cold water anyways
jockofuel.com get it get some
subscription if you need it go to Wawa
go to Vitamin Shop go to GNC get the
drinks GNC go to the military commissary
series Hannaford Dash doors wake from
ShopRite HEB
Meyer we're in Harris Teeter now
Lifetime Fitness and a bunch of other
small gyms out there you can get it Jiu
Jitsu gyms they're bringing it in
CrossFit gyms are bringing it if you're
a CrossFit gym or you're a Jiu Jitsu gym
and you want to have Jocko Fielder email
jfsales jockoffuel.com we'll get you
hooked up with that wholesale account
you can deal it like a dealer yeah put
that good stuff the good stuff the good
stuff so there you go also remember
originusa.com talked a little bit about
that today slavery is a real thing
slavery's not an ancient thing one of
the many things we've outsourced yes yes
so slavery's happening right now
you might be supporting it unknowingly
if you're buying something from China
you're supporting it 100 percent
don't do that
instead go to originusa.com buy
something that's made in America 100
from the dirt to the shirt
from the cotton
to the pants
from the copy to the bottoms that
doesn't really rhyme kind of close I
like it we're getting there uh hunt gear
we're making two if you've seen the have
you got the the training gear yet you
probably haven't gotten it yet what oh
the hunt one no between TRX Train Roll
execute the TRX line oh damn no no no no
so we got that coming so it's it's
basically now we got the the athletic
shirts coming out that are quick dry
wicking yeah you know antibacterial
horny Arts they're they're available
quite yet but they're coming yeah
they're coming
um yeah we're gonna make everything
everything that I wear yeah we're gonna
get made in America originusa.com get
through that also chocolate store well
hey we're all on the path this is the
path prepared
part of the path capable part of the
past strong part of the path stronger
the better smarter the better you know
you understand we know it's not on the
path Donuts we're gonna we're not we're
gonna avoid that same thing
um but you want to represent on the path
jockostore.com this is where you can get
discipline equal stream shirts good
Shirts by the way quality very wearable
um short Locker on there as well it's a
subscription scenario where you get a
new shirt every month those are fun
people like them so you can check that
out too if you want something get
something chocolate store.com also
subscribe to this podcast subscribe to
Jocko underground.com subscribe to the
YouTube channel Jocko what is it called
Jocko podcast YouTube channel
podcast officials check out origin USA
check out Jocko fuel
for YouTube channels check out
psychological warfare check out Dakota
Meyer
he's just out there getting after it
right now he's making stuff for you to
hang on your wall as well so go to
flipsidecanvas.com books get this book
right here prepared
a manual for surviving worst case
scenarios by Mike Glover founder of
fieldcraft Survivor forward by Jack Carr
look at that dude there you go I got
some quotes on the back
uh Mike Glover is one of the best
instructors I've ever trained and worked
with his experience in the global war on
terror and his ability to combine that
with his intellect equals survival
wisdom so the equation is easy
experience plus IQ plus communication
equals wisdom wisdom equals Survivor
that's from Evan Hafer CEO and founder
of Black Rifle Coffee Company
got it caught in here from Chad robichow
got a quote on here from Tim Kennedy and
got a quote on here from Andy Stumpf
they're all saying by this freaking book
that's what they're saying so there you
go get that book
um comes out June 6th it's available for
pre-order right now final spin
wrote that book
that book is going places we'll just
keep it at that right now we'll just say
that for now uh leadership strategy and
tactics but I read a bunch of books kids
but get to get your kids the kids books
if you need help with leadership go to
echelonfront.com
we got all kinds of things that will
help you with your leadership in your
company and your family in your life
come and check out one of our events
come and check out our online training
extreme ownership Academy get involved
in that extreme ownership.com you can
come and learn how to interact with
other human beings better it will help
you in all aspects of your life
if you want to help other people if you
want to help service members active and
retired you want to help their families
gold star families check out Markley's
mom mommy she's got a charity
organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org also don't forget about heroes
and
horses.org Micah Fink
right now he's bathing in an ice bath
while eating a raw salmon that he caught
on the end of a stick so check it out
he's helping veterans
all over go up and find themselves in
the wilderness once again if you want to
connect with Mike Glover
fieldcraftsurvival.com
Facebook Instagram Twitter YouTube it's
all at fieldcraft survival
Mike is on Instagram Mike dot a DOT
Glover he's also on Twitter Mike a
glover1
he's also got American contingency.com
check all that out also for us Echoes at
Echo Charles
he's rebuilding his Twitter life which
fell apart when he got attacked
[Music]
cyber Craft Survival yeah you got a zero
yeah I did run into the ditch yes yeah
so go follow Echo Charles on if you like
Twitter hopefully he won't get hacked
and send you a bunch of dumb messages
again again
uh I'm on there too at Draco willink
just watch out for the algorithm man
that thing's trying to grab you it's
trying to control your brain it's
literally trying to control your brain
feeding you dopamine
feeding you little things that you want
to see that make you feel good for Point
Zero two seconds and then it feeds you
another one and then it feeds you
another one next thing you know it's
been two and a half hours you've been
looking at the gram s don't do it
so there you go
thanks once again to Mike Glover for
joining us thanks for sharing your
knowledge
thanks for the service and sacrifice you
made for this country and to all the
military personnel out there around the
world who are staying prepared to
protect our nation and our freedom
thanks to all of you also thanks to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emt's dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all the First Responders
thanks to all of you for also staying
prepared
as you protect us here at home and to
everyone else out there listen you don't
know when things are going to go
sideways
you don't know
you don't know when disaster or an
accident or medical emergency or any
other form of Mayhem might strike
but
you should know that these things
will happen to you at some point in some
form and there won't be time to call for
help
or help won't be able to come quick
enough and all
of it
will be on you
it'll all be on you to protect your
family to render care to save lives
possibly to take lives at some point all
of this will be on you
so
please
for yourself for your family for your
friends for your community and for this
country please
get prepared
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko out